Also ich war ein Teil eines Hackerspaces in Seattle namens Hackerbot Labs und dann bin ich auf das Hackers on a Plane-Tour in Europa um all diese Hackerspaces in Deutschland und Österreich zu besuchen. Und mein Freund George und ich haben eine in New York City.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 134 und es ist eine weitere und vorerst letzte Folge hier aus Wien bei meiner kleinen Stippvisite im Nachbarland, wo ich schon eine ganz Menge interessantes Zeug zusammengekramt habe und ich hatte da auch eine sehr lange Wunschliste, die war auch noch viel länger als ich jetzt hier habe abarbeiten können, aber wie das immer so ist, die Zeit ist nur sehr begrenzt und die Leute sind auch manchmal krank und so. Aber umso mehr freue ich mich jetzt hier begrüßen zu dürfen Astera, hallo. Und den Johannes.
Ja hallo.
Du warst ja schon mal da.
Ja ich war schon da, aber woanders, in Berlin noch, glaube ich war das.
Genau, da haben wir uns über deine monochromischen Aktivitäten unterhalten.
Ja so ist es, aber heute glaube ich nicht. Heute reden wir über was anderes.
Heute reden wir über was anderes. Ich hatte jetzt in der letzten Sendung auch deinen Kollegen am Start.
Ah, den Roland über die Piratengeschichte.
Über die Piratengeschichte, genau. Zeigst du mal wieder mal, wie bunt das Monochrom-Universum ist. Aber wie schon gesagt, hier geht es jetzt mal nicht um Monochrom, sondern ich habe euch beide mal rausgepickt, um ein Phänomen zu besprechen, was ja aber auch schon mal ein Thema war, allerdings eher so ein bisschen hintenrum und auch noch zu einer sehr frühen Zeit. Kurz, es soll gehen um Hackerspaces und die entsprechenden Strukturen, die sich da in den letzten Jahren herausgebildet haben. Ich hatte in Ausgabe 55 von Chaosradio Express mit Enki und dem Flo gesprochen, vom MetaLab über das MetaLab und das war ja Ende 2007 und das war so ein Zeitpunkt, da ist das Chaos-Communication-Camp, das letzte, war gerade gelaufen, man war so auf dem Weg zum nächsten Kongress und was ich dort halt abzeichnete, abgesehen davon, dass das MetaLab als solches auch schon begann in voller Blüte zu stehen, dass sich eine Bewegung aufmacht, scheinbar so aus den deutschsprachigen Landen in die Welt zurück hinaus solche Orte zu gründen, genannt Hackerspaces, es gab dann erste Bewegungen, vor allem in New York und San Francisco, eben sich ähnliche Orte zu bauen und sich dort auch eine ähnliche Art und Weise zusammenzufinden, wie diese Community es eben live erlebt hat in Europa beim Kongress, beim Camp und auch vielen anderen Orten, wie auch eben dem MetaLab, die alle so ein bisschen da so eine Role-Model-Funktion.
Ich hab nie mal was abgeschaut.
Genau, hier lief es auf einmal irgendwie anders.
Also nicht nur abgeschaut, sondern da ist eine ganze kamprische Explosion losgegangen. Also im Jahre 2008 ging es ja auf einmal quasi, das war ja fast logarithmisch, wie die Sachen losgebrochen sind.
Vor allem auch deshalb, weil nach diesem Camp eben, wie gesagt, wo Hackers on a Plane zum ersten Mal stattgefunden hat, also eine Gruppe von ein paar Hackern, die gemeinsam ein Flugticket buchen, um zur Haar zu fliegen und dann dort das erste Mal über...
Nicht zur Haar, sondern zum CCC.
Zum CCC Camp, richtig. Die dann zum ersten Mal diesen Begriff Hackerspace irgendwie als eine Bewegung sehen. Mehr als, ja es gibt den CCC und das ist so eine schöne Einrichtung. Die dann darüber erfahren, dass es solche Spaces in so vielen Leuten gibt, die die ja auch abgefahren sind.
Der 2007er Chaos Camp war auf jeden Fall so ein Brütgrund oder so eine Mehrlösung für viele Leute. Hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass einige Leute, vor allem Leute, die andere sehr begeistern können, wie der Brie Pettis zum Beispiel, der ja in der Do-It-Yourself-Community ein großer Name war und immer noch ist, der ja auch einer der maßgeblichen Trägerpersönlichkeiten für den New Yorker Hackerspace NYC Resistor war. Der hat natürlich mit seiner Überzeugungskraft da viel leisten können. Aber alleine das ist es nicht zu sagen. Also man muss schon feststellen, dass da genau zu der Zeit, noch nicht ganz in der Krise drin, aber sie zeichnet sich überall schon irgendwie ab, dass da so eine Kreativitätswelle am Kochen war. Und die Leute wollten einfach was tun und sich engagieren und was basteln. Jenseits der ganzen Geschichte, dass man halt natürlich irgendwo in Technikfirmen arbeitet und da irgendwie den Kurbierer und die Techniken zweckentfremdet und für sich selbst nutzt, wollten die Leute glaube ich schon irgendwie auch noch so einen Ort, wo man gemeinsam quasi so eine kreative technologische Praxis ausüben kann.
Das schafft eine ganz neue Bandbreite von Motivationen.
Bevor wir da noch weiter einsteigen, wollte ich erst noch mal so ein bisschen auch so auf eure Wahrnehmung vor dieser ganzen Zeit noch mal eingehen. Vor allem erstmal noch mal vielleicht zu dir, Astera. Du bist ja nun auch schon seit Jahr und Tag und Ewigkeiten so als digitale Eingeborene unterwegs.
Ein bisschen, ich...
Was ist denn so deine...
Ich spanke immer zwischen den Gebieten irgendwo dahin.
Ja gut, und wann bist du da so das erste Mal reingeschwankt?
Reingeschwankt würde ich sagen, wie ich angefangen habe, an der Universität für Angewandte Kunst zu studieren. In Wien, in Wien. Da habe ich eine Lehrposition bekommen und das Computerstudio quasi betreut und dessen Klassen. Da kommt man dann mal so ins Webdesign rein, über das alltägliche, ich schaffe mir meine Online-Präsenz selbst, Ding und ja, Flash programmieren. Die Sachen, die ändern, doch mehr interessieren, mehr man versucht. Ich habe damals 3D-Renderings gemacht und ein bisschen mitgeforscht an der mathematischen Abteilung und dann rutscht man wieder mehr in die Mathematik hinein. Es eröffnet sich eine ganz neue Welt, die man irgendwie aus der Schule und der Mathematik nicht kennt. Es ist alles ganz neu und aufregend und dann geht man halt von einem Schritt zum nächsten.
Und wie bist du denn so dieser Hacker-Nerd-Kultur entgegengerollt?
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Ich glaube, es ist eine etwas peinliche Antwort. Ich erinnere mich noch.
Was Peinliches?
Ja, unbedingt. Das Methalab habe ich ja vorher nicht gekannt für das erste Jahr seines Bestehens. Also ich habe mal immer wieder gehört, ja, da ist das. Und dann bin ich vorbeigegangen und es war irgendwie kellerlokal und so.
Ich erinnere mich noch, damals, wie du es noch nicht gekannt hast, hast du da irgendwie so gemeint, ist das nicht das, wo diese ganzen komischen Typen da immer so abhängen oder so? Ich glaube, du hattest ein leichtes Vorurteil dem Methalab gegenüber.
Ich bin tatsächlich ein paar Mal vorbeigegangen und das war seltsam. Bis ich dann von einem Haufen junger Methalaboranten, männlicher, mitgezerrt wurde, wie man das so macht, mit Mädchen, die man irgendwo trifft.
Ach so, du wurdest sozusagen einfach so zwangs-eingemeindet.
Naja, ich wurde nicht wirklich eingemeindet. Ich habe mich selbst sehr eingenistet, muss ich sagen.
Und dann hat sie aber auch nicht losgelassen?
Vorallem nicht. Es wird immer interessanter. Die Auseinandersetzung mit seltsamen Menschen ist mir ein großes Anliegen geworden.
Was würdest du denn sagen als dann partiell Außenstehende? Was macht die Faszination aus an der Stelle? Was hat dich dann dazu bewogen, auch an eine Szene anzudocken, die ja dann auch immer extrem männlich dominiert ist? Das ist ja auch klar. Was ist der Reiz? Was ist der Unterschied zu anderen?
Naja, der Reiz, den ich prinzipiell am Leben sehe, ist das Dazulernen. Das hatte ich immer schon. Ich sehe etwas, es sieht interessant aus, ich muss genau wissen, wie es funktioniert, ich möchte es auseinandernehmen, ich möchte dazulernen. Und dann interessiert mich irgendwann nach ein paar Monaten wieder was anderes. Und das ist nicht immer einfach so alleine. Und dann gibt es mal was Größeres, was interessanter wird, aber man kann sich das nicht recht erklären. Und die Zeit geht aus, man hat niemanden, mit dem man drüber spricht und so. Und so verliert sich die Motivation relativ rasch. Jetzt, wenn man tatsächlich an einem Projekt arbeitet oder versucht, irgendwas aufzuarbeiten, im Rahmen von einem Hackerspace wie der MetaLab, dann hat man da diese ganzen anderen Menschen rund herum, die sich dann auch dafür interessieren, die immer mal wieder Fragen drüber stellen, die man fragen, fragen kann, darüber, wie irgendwas funktioniert oder nicht, weil sie dieses Problem vielleicht schon mal gelöst haben. Und man hat diesen Ort, der nicht wie in der Freizeit ist. Man kommt quasi aus der Arbeit, aus dem Dayjob, was immer, nach Hause und macht das eine oder andere, aber es liegt halt alles in der Wohnung herum. Und dann geht man wieder in die Arbeit und tut da halt seine Arbeit und kommt wieder nach Hause. Sondern man geht dezidiert auf einen anderen Flecken, nur um das jetzt zu tun, um sich darauf zu fokussieren, um da jetzt eben an einem Projekt zu arbeiten oder zu lernen.
Und da gibt es auch einen schönen soziologischen Begriff dafür, nämlich der dritte Raum. Also das ist genau das, was die Astera jetzt beschrieben hat. Dass es quasi Räume gibt, die nicht quasi Wohnraum sind und die auch nicht Arbeitsstätte sind, sondern sowas dazwischen. So eine eigenartige Hybridform. Und eine Soziologie heißt es eben dritte Räume, Third Spaces. Und Hackerspaces sind ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür, dass es auch sehr gut funktionieren kann. Also jenseits dieser relativ klar definierten bürgerlichen Weltvorstellungen. Ist das jeder Kegelklub? Warum nicht? Profi-Kegelklubs? Na gut, okay, da müsste man jetzt wahrscheinlich eine Soziologin oder Soziologen herholen.
Kegelklubs sind eher als Freizeit-Hangout, wo man sich trifft.
Der Kegelklub, das ist eine gute Frage eigentlich, weil es geht ja quasi immer noch um die Definition, was der Hackerspace eigentlich ist. Und meine Definition ziehe ich eher aus einer Vergangenheit, weil ich ja quasi auch in meinem Manifest, das ich mit Frank A. Schneider geschrieben habe, versuche die Vergangenheit der Hackerspaces zu beleuchten, um quasi eine bessere Zukunft für Hackerspaces zu entwickeln. Und wenn du zum Beispiel nach dem Bowling-Club fragst, ein Freund von mir, der Michi Zeltner, der beim Hackerspace in London dabei ist, da gibt es eine Person bei diesem Hackerspace, der definitiv sagt, für mich ist ein Hackerspace nichts anderes als ein Gymnastik-Club, wo ich hingehe und wo ich halt quasi nicht Fitnessübungen mache, sondern halt quasi Coding-Übungen mache und mehr nicht sozusagen.
Mentale Fitness.
So, mentale Fitness, ja. Das ist aber für mich, für meine Definition von Hackerspace, definitiv zu wenig. Also da würde ich auch quasi auch einen politischen Kampfbegriff setzen und sagen, also abseits der Definition, was dritte Räume der Soziologie sind, weil da gibt es eine klare Definition. Hackerspace muss mehr sein als nur ein erweitertes Wohnzimmer, wo man halt abhängt und Nintendo spielt und ab und zu mal lötet. Also das kann es nicht sein.
Da gehen wir später auf jeden Fall nochmal drauf ein, auf diesen Text und was das auch ausgelöst hat. Aber jetzt vielleicht nochmal kurz zu dir, Astera, und dem Verhältnis. MetaLab war sozusagen dein Inkubator. Das war so der Ort, wo du quasi deinen dritten Raum gefunden hast, wenn man jetzt mal bei dem Bild bleibt.
Ich hatte halt vorher meinen dritten Raum in meinem Atelier, aber es ist nicht dasselbe. Du teilst das Atelier mit jemand anderem, weil das ist natürlich sehr teuer, vor allem in Wien.
Und es ist halt auch eher der zweite Raum, wenn man jetzt mal der Lohn folgt, oder?
Also dein dritter Raum wäre wahrscheinlich eher die Uni gewesen, oder irgendwelche Laborsituationen oder so was, aber auch nicht wirklich. Nein, nein, stimmt nicht ganz.
Nein, nein. Im Atelier habe ich ja nicht gearbeitet. Ich habe da schon in der Agentur gearbeitet. Es war auf jeden Fall, ich komme aus der Arbeit raus, ich gehe ins Atelier. Und dann irgendwann hat sich das auch nicht mehr rentiert, das zu zahlen und es hat sich irgendwie aufgelöst.
Aber es ist ja schon auffällig, das weiß ich natürlich auch aus meiner eigenen Vergangenheit, dass diese Orte vor allem dadurch besonders attraktiv abstrahlen, dass man dort so viele Leute findet, die einfach unheimlich devot in ihrem Thema drinhängen und einfach mit einer Energie und Begeisterung Sachen nachforschen, die an sich einen Sog erzeugt, den man sich dann eben schwer entziehen kann. Das würdest du auch so sehen?
Ja, das seh ich auf jeden Fall so. Daher kommt dann auch irgendwo meine Begriffsdefinition, wenn man das überhaupt definitionschimpfen darf, von einem Hacker-Space, wenn ich mir das Wort anschaue, das zerlegt halt in den ersten Teil Hacker und den zweiten Space. Ich mein, Space ist offensichtlich eine physische Lokation. Bei Hacker wird's schon schwieriger. Das seh ich nicht nur als ein Mensch, der halt gern codet, ein Mensch, der sich mit Software auseinandersetzt, mit reverse engineering auseinandersetzt, mit phone freaking auseinandersetzt. Auch nicht einer, der einfach nur Hardware gerne angreift, bastelt, modifiziert. Wir haben eine Menge, also in einer Menge Hackerspaces gibt's einen hohen Anteil an Leuten, die man quasi so in den künstlerischen Bereich einordnen kann. Nicht nur digitale Kunst, dann generell Kunst. Und die halt diese Schnittstellen dann suchen, die sich automatisch ergeben, dadurch, dass du eben interagierst mit Leuten, die generell interessiert sind an neuen Thematiken, an Technologien, die nicht einfach nur User sind. Nicht im Tron-Sinne, jetzt war das der User ja noch. Was ganz Besonderes. Sondern die einfach nicht als gegeben hinnehmen, was ihnen die Welt so vorschmeißt im Supermarkt. Und dann benutzen sie halt ihr iPhone. Sondern die, die das für sich adaptieren wollen, oder die dahinter schauen wollen, woher kommt das eigentlich und wofür kann ich das noch verwenden. Und das können sie auf jeden Bereich tun. Und dementsprechend bin ich der Meinung, dass Hacking, dieses Dahinterschauen, dieses sich dafür interessieren und es verstehen wollen, auseinandernehmen wollen, modifizieren wollen.
Grenzen überschreiten?
Auf jeden Fall. Grenzen nach hinten überschreiten auch.
Und ob ein Hacker-Space funktioniert oder nicht funktioniert, also ob das quasi eine aktive, flourischende Community ist oder nicht, hängt auch damit zusammen, wie die Leute im Space mit diesem neuen umgehen. Weil gerade in der Nerd- und Hacker- und Hackerinnenkultur, muss man auch dazu sagen, ist es ja so, dass es auf jeden Fall auch so Abgrenzungsmechanismen gibt. Also sagen, wir witzeln über unsere Witze und ihr versteht sie nicht und so. Also es ist immer so ein ausschließendes Moment in der Hacker-Kultur und Hackerinnenkultur ja auch drinnen sozusagen. Aber dort, wo es funktioniert, und zum Beispiel Noisebridge ist ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür für einen Hacker-Space, der quasi so einen radikalen Inklusionismus betreibt, der einfach niemanden ausschließt und wer auch immer kommen kann und wer auch immer machen kann und machen will, der darf das auch. Und egal, ob das jetzt quasi jonglieren ist oder Ruby on Rails programmieren, das ist vollkommen egal. Und das wäre ja auch eine schöne Definition, finde ich, quasi was Hacken ist eigentlich. Also quasi diesen erweiterten Hacking-Begriff. Sich quasi Wissen aneignen und verwenden und weitergeben und auch teilen. Also, ich finde, beim Hacken steckt ein großer Solidarbegriff auch drinnen. Obwohl es natürlich immer quasi darum geht, dass man natürlich mehr weiß als der andere und damit angeben kann. Und so, dass ich natürlich gerade in diesen ganzen Wissenssoziotopen immer ganz besonders speziell, aber im Endeffekt geht es doch darum, hey, ich habe da was Cooles, ich zeige euch das jetzt und ihr könnt das auch machen. Also das ist das wesentliche Element. Es ist ein wesentlicher Open-Source-Gedanke, wobei ich jetzt quasi diesen Open-Source-Begriff gar nicht so überstrapazieren möchte. Also da kann man dann nochmal drüber reden, inwieweit das sinnvoll ist oder nicht. Aber Hackerspaces funktionieren glaube ich dann besonders gut, wenn das neue quasi inkorporiert werden kann, ohne es quasi abzulehnen. Also es gibt ja auch Spaces, die so klein sind und gezielt dann zum Beispiel dann verlangen, nicht auf der hackerspaces.org gelistet zu werden oder nur fünf Mitglieder haben oder nur zehn Mitglieder. Und das ist dann ganz geheim. Es gibt zum Beispiel einen Club, würde ich es fast nennen, weil es eigentlich kein hackerspace ist in Boston zum Beispiel. Also da weiß niemand genau, wo das ist. Die paar Leute, die dort hingehen, das ist auch relativ klein. Das ist irgendwie so dieser Loft nach Fahre, dieses hackerspaces dort in Boston. Aber das ist natürlich ein hackerspace, aber es ist eigentlich mehr ein Privatclub. Und wenn es nur ein Privatclub ist, dann erfüllt es eigentlich nicht die notwendigen Voraussetzungen dafür, ein funktionierender hackerspace zu sein.
Ich weiß nicht, wer sagt die?
Weil es gibt ja auch diese Definition der Shared Working Spaces und Shared Working Environments. Und das ist eigentlich kein Hackspace. Also zum Beispiel ein Freund von mir, Eddie Codell aus San Francisco, der hat eben die Head Factory. Das ist in so einer Randlage in San Francisco. Und dort kommen halt jeden Tag in der Früh 20 Leute mit ihrem Notebooks und arbeiten dort und trinken dort Kaffee und haben auch interessante Gespräche und nützen den Raum dort gemeinsam und zahlen auch für den Raum gemeinsam. Aber das ist eigentlich kein Hackspace, weil diese Leute kommen quasi nur deswegen dorthin, weil ihnen bei der Arbeit zu Hause eigentlich zu fad wäre oder sich einfach ein Büro nicht leisten können. Und deswegen gibt es dann diese Shared Working Environments, aber das ist nicht ein Hackspace. Also ein Hackspace hat schon quasi was, da geht es um eine Gemeinschaft. Und diese Shared Working Environments haben quasi nichts an Gemeinschaft, außer dass man sich halt quasi an einem Ort trifft. Und da kann man wieder darüber diskutieren, wieso der Ort dann wichtig ist, weil der Ort nur ein Ort ist, ist ja dann auch nicht ein Hackspace.
Also diese Coworking-Bewegung, das ist ja auch etwas, was in letzter Zeit sehr stark wird. Ich würde schon sagen, das hat schon so sein Stück weit eine Parallele.
Es hat eine Parallele, ja.
Das alle entdeckt haben, dass eben auch so dieses Zufällige motiviert werden, dieses auch auf andere Ideen gestoßen zu werden, die man einfach nicht hat, wenn man seine eigenen vier Wände nicht verlässt. Auch diese menschliche Interaktion, die da zwangsläufig mit dabei ist und sicherlich auch das spielerische, was immer wieder dazwischenkommt, vielleicht mal auch im Metalab, wenn man reinkommt. Da gibt es dann halt auch diesen schlimmen Raum, wo irgendwie einfach gedaddelt wird, bis zum geht nicht mehr. Das gehört natürlich auch dazu. Also was wichtig ist, glaube ich, dass es eine gegenseitige Beeinflussung ist, an der Stelle, dass man eben auch arbeiten gar nicht mehr so, also dass auch der zweite Raum sich zumindest so in Richtung dritten Raum gerne entwickeln möchte, aber nicht so sehr unsere Seriosität zu verlieren.
Das wäre dann quasi von einer linken Kritik heraus zu sagen, das ist eigentlich der falsche Weg. Also eigentlich sollte sich der Arbeitsraum, quasi die ökonomische Notwendigkeit und das Ganze quasi nicht in den Hackerspace rein verschleppen lassen. Eigentlich sollte man das draußen lassen, weil das sind ja natürlich auch kolonisatorische Prinzipien.
Ich würde sagen, dass es schon versucht, an Hackerspace zu sein und sich explizit davon was zu holen. Aber es versucht sich als eigener Lebensraum, dadurch auch wieder ein bisschen lebendiger zu machen, indem man einfach bestimmte Aspekte aufgreift, wie sie auch die Hackerspaces, aber nicht nur die aufgreifen.
Ja, verstehe schon. Was ich meine, meine grundsätzliche Kritik daran wäre, dass natürlich quasi die Arbeitszeit, also eigentlich ist das ja quasi eine klassische Form von neoliberaler Kritik wäre das sozusagen, dass quasi das Arbeiten quasi die Freizeit immer mehr und mehr übernimmt und auch kopiert. Und das wäre quasi eine Kritik, die man quasi an solchen Coworking-Spaces beißern könnte.
Okay, aber ich denke, soweit geht es da auch in der Regel gar nicht. Aber das ist egal. Aber das ist auch wiederum von Space zu Space unterschiedlich sein. Tatsache ist, die Leute wollen wieder zusammenkommen und man kann dem was abgewinnen, vor allem auch diese Netzwerke, die sich daraus ergeben. Ich denke, das ist ja auch ein großer Wert, der jetzt bei diesem Coworking beabfällt, dass man ja nicht nur sich die Räume teilt, sondern auch in zunehmendem Maße die Projekte teilt. Und das dann natürlich eine räumliche Nähe auch was hat. Aber da wollen wir jetzt gar nicht mal so hängen bleiben. Ich wollte noch mal kurz zurück, vielleicht auch noch mal zu dir, Astera, du hast ja das Meta-Lab kennengelernt, aber das ist ja nicht das einzige, was du kennengelernt hast. An Hackerspaces nein. Bevor jetzt diese zweite Welle begonnen hat, was hast du denn noch dann kennengelernt? Oder an Orten, die jetzt in irgendeiner Form für das, was du danach gemacht hast, da kommen wir ja gleich drauf, die Hackerspaces Org-Bewegung, was sozusagen entscheidend war, da überhaupt die Initiative zu ergreifen.
Es waren eigentlich größtenteils Künstler-Vereinigungen, vor allem von Modedesignern, nachdem ich mich später sehr viel für Mode interessiert habe, wo man sich eben auch quasi zusammengetan hat, damals ganz, ganz, ganz schlechte ökonomische Lage für Modedesigner, wo man sich zusammengetan hat, um eben gemeinsam ein Atelier zu haben, eher ein Co-Working-Space eigentlich, einfach weil gerade auch als Modedesigner hat man diese ganzen Maschinen, da hat man mal so seine Overlock-Maschine, die ist jetzt nicht so billig, und dann hast du noch einen Coverlock, und dann hast du noch ein paar andere Maschinen, und das kann man sich A, nicht alles leisten, das kann man sich B, auch nicht alles in das Wohnzimmer stellen, weil dann ist das Wohnzimmer voll, Das ist voll und dann hat man auch keinen Freiraum mehr zu Hause. Und man möchte halt wohin gehen, um zu arbeiten. Das ist wirklich wie ein Co-Working-Space. Aber es hat eben diese Parallele zu einem Hacker-Space und da würde ich sagen, die Grenzen sind immer fließend in diesem Bereich. Dass man eben gemeinsam sich sein Environment anschafft und sich das wohin stellt an einem Platz, sodass es jeder nutzen kann, sodass jeder was davon hat, dass man gemeinsam quasi mal zusammengelegt hat auf ein paar Geräte und dann passt auch jeder drauf auf. Und generell dieses Bilden von diesen Communities, die sich gegenseitig unterstützen, dadurch, dass du schaust dir mal an, was macht der andere, du wirst davon inspiriert, aber du kannst auch den anderen nachweislich motivieren, was Neues zu machen, ist da wie dort einfach vorrangig. Noch mehr als dieses, wir schaffen uns jetzt ein paar Geräte an. Also das war wirklich, warum man hingeht.
Was ja in San Francisco zum Beispiel sehr interessant ist, ist, da gibt es eine lange Tradition von so Shared Workshops, also wenn Leute sich quasi eine Maschine nicht leisten können alleine, dann kaufen sie halt quasi zu viel oder zu fünft die Maschine und benutzen die dann dort und haben so gemeinsame Arbeitsräume, wo dann Maschinen drinstehen und CNC-Fräsen oder irgend sowas, aber es gab lange Jahre, jahrzehntelang nichts Vergleichbares mit einem Hacker-Space, was natürlich gerade in San Francisco eine interessante Beobachtung ist, weil San Francisco nähe zur Silicon Valley, immer auch ein bisschen durchgeknallte Typen und so, warum gab es da keinen Hacker-Space und so. Und ich habe mit einem Freund dort gesprochen, der hat gemeint, dass es damit auch zu tun hatte, dass sich das so ein bisschen zerspragelt hat, wie man in Österreich sagt, dass es quasi so Workshop-Environments gab, wo halt Maschinen rumstanden und dass sich dann quasi die Community um die Maschinen versammelt hat und nicht um sich selbst herum. Also das ist quasi, dass die Maschinen das Zentrum waren und man geht halt quasi so, wie man halt zum Supermarkt geht, geht man halt dann zur CNC-Fräse einmal im Monat und macht da irgendwas, wenn man das dort machen möchte. Aber der Zusammenhalt war quasi nicht wirklich ein sozialer, solidarischer, wir arbeiten aber gemeinsam an was sozusagen. Und das Noisebreed, also der San Francisco Hacker Space, hat schon damit zu tun, dass es ein sehr, sehr extrem sozialer Raum ist, extrem wenig Platz. Aber es gibt quasi, die würden jeden Tag fünf Workshops dort abhalten, wenn sie mehr Platz hätten und mehr Ressourcen hätten. Und deswegen versuchen sie auch gerade zu expandieren. Also das hat quasi dort einen Need in der Community getroffen, dass jetzt dort so ein Hacker Space aufgetaucht ist, der so ganz klassisch nach so einem europäischen Prinzip eigentlich auch aufgebaut ist, mit Basisdemokratie und sehr Konsensorientiert und so, was ja in Amerika, in US-Amerika ja nicht unbedingt immer so quasi eine große Tugend ist, quasi alles auf Konsens aufzubauen oder so. Da ist dann schneller mal quasi der, der am lautesten schreit, der dann auch entscheidet. Aber das finde ich sehr spannend und also was ich gerne einbringen würde ist, dass man natürlich, wenn man von Hacker Spaces spricht und du willst dir dann eh auch noch was von hackerspaces.org erzählen, was ja quasi so ein Dachverband vielleicht am ersten ist oder sowas. Es klingt böse, die deutschen Wörter klingen immer so böse, aber zumindest in einem Ort, dann klingt es gleich wieder besser. Also ein Ort auf jeden Fall, wo man quasi auch was findet, Informationen, welche anderen Leute gibt es und dass viele dieser Spaces ja wirklich, wirklich sehr, sehr unterschiedlich sind. Also man kann natürlich die meisten quasi, könnte man wahrscheinlich durchfiltern und sagen, aha, da ist wieder so ein Galerie-Raum, hat sich jetzt auch in die Liste reingeschrieben, kann man mal darüber diskutieren, ob ein Galerie-Raum jetzt quasi ein Hacker-Space ist oder nicht. Aber abgesehen davon finde ich es gut, dass Leute das als Affinität auch gut finden und auf die Liste drauf wollen und da quasi auch dabei sein wollen bei der ganzen Sache. Also nur als ein Beispiel, man braucht ja nur das Meta-Lab hernehmen und zum Beispiel NYC Resistor und das sind beides klassische Hacker-Spaces, aber sie funktionieren nach vollkommen anderen Prinzipien, also das Meta-Lab ist eher noch so was wie eine Mischung aus einem Jugendclub und einem Hacker-Space und NYC Resistor ist eher so eine Mischung aus einem Hacker-Space oder einem Arbeitsraum, quasi der sehr stark auf so Workshops und Arbeiten und Projekt orientierter ist. Aber das heißt jetzt nicht, dass Meta-Lab irgendwie schlechter oder weniger gut wäre als quasi NYC Resistor, die im Schnitt wahrscheinlich einen größeren Output an herzeigbaren Projekten haben. Aber um das geht es ja auch gar nicht. Also ich möchte gar nicht auf eine Ökonomisierung hinaus.
Es hat sicherlich immer ein Spiegel der lokalen Kultur, natürlich auch, der unterschiedlichen Bedürfnisse, denke ich.
Auf jeden Fall, aber auch im deutschsprachigen Raum zum Beispiel, das Meta-Lab und zum Beispiel die C-Base zu vergleichen ist relativ schwierig. Die C-Base zum Beispiel alleine von der Architektur her, das ist eher so ein immersive environment mit diesem Raumschiff und diesem Raumstationsthema und so. Und gleichzeitig ist es ja auch ein Nightclub bis zu einem gewissen Grad, das heißt, es ist eher so ein Hackspace-Nightclub, was auch eine ganz spezifische Sache ist. Natürlich auch gut zu Berlin passt, also Selbstverständnis.
Sie haben ja auch einen großen Anteil an Leuten, die sich als Künstler verstehen. Aber dazu muss man sagen, dass das Meta-Lab auch ein deutliches Vorbild sich genommen hat an der C-Base und das ja auch so machen wollten. Wir sind jetzt auch eine Art Club für Partys, wenn man das nicht hat, finden zu.
Ich finde auch, gerade räumlich ist das Meta-Lab und die C-Base ganz gut zu vergleichen.
Von der Größe her auch.
Ja, auch so von diesem Prinzip. Man kommt rein und es gibt halt vor allem erstmal den einen großen Raum, der sich immer wieder neu konfiguriert, je nachdem, was gerade ansteht. Da gibt es in dem Sinne keine feste Struktur. Also da mag sich vielleicht das ein oder andere häufiger wiederfinden, aber wenn halt eine bestimmte Veranstaltung einen bestimmten Bedarf hat, dann wird eben der Raum danach gestaltet. Und drumherum Labor und so weiter, das sind dann eben die Dinge, die eben eine definierte Aufgabe haben und dann auch entsprechend gestaltet sind. Also ich sehe da schon durchaus Parallelen, aber ganz klar, also die sind halt auch alle, die sind alle vergleichbar. Der Vergleich fällt halt mal so und mal so aus. Aber es gibt eben auch große Ähnlichkeiten und es gibt große Unterschiede. Vielleicht jetzt nochmal kurz so zu dieser Geschichte, die wir jetzt schon ein paar Mal angesprochen haben, die wir so auch nochmal erzählen müssen, vor allem weil ich ja an der Stelle quasi bei diesem Podcast über das MetaLab da eigentlich hab aufhören müssen, weil das befand sich einfach gerade alles in der, ja, da dieser Urknall, der hat irgendwie schon stattgefunden, so, aber die Kugel war irgendwie noch nicht so richtig groß. Die Orte, die du ansprichst, NYC, Resista und so weiter, das waren schon gegründete Projekte, aber ich glaube, zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es den Ort auch, glaube ich, noch nicht oder war gerade eben erst gefunden oder so und auch die ganzen anderen amerikanischen Projekte waren im Wesentlichen erst mal dabei, ihre Kultur zu finden und dort zu finden.
Noise Bridge in San Francisco, ich meine, wir reden da so, als ob das da, also Noise Bridge in San Francisco, die haben, ich erinnere mich noch deutlich daran, wie wir die Ars Electronica, die Konferenz über Sex und Technologie in San Francisco, von Monochrom aus organisiert haben, in San Francisco letztes Jahr, im Ende September 2008. Da kam Jake Applebaum rein und hat gesagt, ich muss jetzt was verkünden, das ist quasi ein historischer Moment. Wir haben den Mietvertrag unterschrieben für Noise Bridge.
Das war Ende 2008 oder 2007?
Das war 2008.
Das war im September 2008.
Ende September 2008 und jetzt haben wir nicht mal ein Jahr später und Noise Bridge ist eine so unglaubliche, wuchernde und brodelnde Suppe geworden, aus dem schon so viel entstanden ist. Das ist fast undenkbar. In weniger als einem Jahr.
Seit Dienstagabend, also für San Francisco jetzt nicht einmal 48 Stunden hier, hat ja Noise Bridge am neuen Space. Der neue Space ist viermal so groß wie das Meta-Lab, also sie expandieren extrem.
Das sind jetzt schon zwei Schritte weiter sozusagen.
Jetzt geht's flott.
Ja genau, jetzt ist Anfang August 2009, ich muss das ab und zu auch mal das Jahr sagen, weil Chaosradio Express wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört werden und da ist es dann schon wichtig, auch mal so einen zeitlichen Anker auszuwerfen. So, la la la, also das Camp war da, es fand das erste Mal Hackers on a Plane statt, also die Amerikaner wurden, das war ja auch so, das war ja im Prinzip, eigentlich haben wir sie ja gehackt, um das jetzt noch mal ein bisschen weiter auszurollen. Der Plan, die Amerikaner wieder ins Boot zu holen, den gab's ja auch beim CCC schon sehr lange. Das war immer die Intention, auch mit der Internationalisierung des Kongresses, da plappere ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen, internationalen Appeal zu schaffen und vor allem auch wirklich den desaströsen Zustand der amerikanischen Hacker-Szene, naja, zumindest kulturell zu beleben. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass es jetzt wirklich ein Ersättungsversuch war, vom Start weg, aber es war ja offensichtlich, dass dort die Gruppen wenig miteinander zu tun hatten, es gab da wenig Kommunikation, es gab halt 2600 und es gab dieses und jenes und Loft und was du schon erwähnt hast, da gab es aber weder viel Kommunikation untereinander, noch gab es wirklich solche Orte, wie wir sie eben zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gewohnt haben. Der Club hat das ja nun schon ganz in den 90er-Jahren überall so langsam aufgebaut und dann gab es auf einmal dieses Moment mit dem MetaLab und einigen anderen Projekten, dass da eben auch so innerhalb Europas so eine Expansionsbewegung stattfand. Dann ist es halt gelungen, in zunehmendem Maße mehr Amerikaner andocken zu lassen und dieses Hackers on a Plane-Projekt hat dann irgendwie alles, das hat dann irgendwie so eine Druckwelle ausgelöst, die so eine Kettenreaktion hat.
Und es war sehr interessant. Ich habe ja mit einem, ich sage jetzt keinen Namen, mit einem amerikanischen Hacker in Wien gesprochen, der sich da im Rahmen dieses Hackers on a Plane, dieser Tour, dieser European Hackerspaces-Tour quasi 2007, da einige Hackerspaces angeschaut hat und der hat mir so ins Gesicht gesagt, so, ich verstehe nicht, er war extrem skeptisch, bevor er auf die Tour gegangen ist, ob er da irgendwas lernen wird aus der ganzen Sache.
Also die Tour war sozusagen die, also Hackers on a Plane, um es noch zusammenzufassen, war so die reise, die kollektive Reise mit dem Flugzeug zum Camp und danach schloss sich noch diese Bus-Tour an, durch einige Hackerspaces, Bochum und so weiter, Metalabdorff.
Genau, Metalab und C4 und weiß Gott was, oder weiß der nicht existierende Gott was. Und der hat mir dann gesagt, er war sehr skeptisch, weil er hat von diesen Hackerspaces schon gehört, aber so, und das ist natürlich wieder so klassische, fast amerikanische, so anacholiberale Tradition, irgendwie so, naja, das kann ja nie im Leben funktionieren. Wenn das alles so anachisch ist bei denen und hin und her und da gibt es keinen Chef und bla bla bla und hin und her, wie kann denn das funktionieren, da hocke ich lieber bei mir zu Hause und starre auf meinen Root und setze mich da keinen großen sozialen Sachen aus und so, das ist immer nur Probleme. Gerade amerikanische Hacker sind extrem dafür bekannt, dass sie auch viel streiten und so und nicht zusammenarbeiten können und da gibt es dann diese Clans und dann gibt es die Cult of the Dead Cow und die mögen die nicht und weiss Gott was, ja. Und der war so extrem überrascht, wie das funktionieren kann. Er hat sich das nicht erklären können, wie das wirklich funktioniert und wie diese Spaces überleben können, ohne ökonomisches Backing im Sinne von, da gibt es jetzt Leute, die damit Kohle verdienen wollen oder da gibt es jetzt Leute, die da jetzt in der Gegend rumpeitschen und anschaffen und so. Er hat es bis heute nicht verstanden, aber er ist mittlerweile aktives Member in einem amerikanischen Hacker-Club und ist dort unglaublich aktiv. Also, den, der ist definitiv gehackt worden. Also, definitiv.
Ja, also es ging wohl so einigen und vor allem hatte ich auch so den Eindruck, dass er…
Ein guter Exploit, glaube ich. Solidarität.
Also, da ging definitiv bei einigen Leuten so. Ich meine, es war ja auch eine schwierige Zeit. Es war noch so ein bisschen so prä-Obama, man wusste gar nicht, wo geht die Reise hin in der amerikanischen Gesellschaft. Alle waren immer total frustriert und wenn sie irgendwie auf den Kongress kamen, also man kriegte ja schon richtig Mitleid. Also, das war… Die kommen dann hin nach Deutschland in den USA, da musst du dich auf jeder Hackerveranstaltung fragen, ist der Typ, der da jetzt hinter mir steht, irgendwie vom FBI oder vom CIA oder ist er wirklich nur interessiert in dem, was ich mache. So ein großes Misstrauen, keine wirklich gelebte Freiheit und dann kommt man irgendwie nach Europa, nach Berlin und wo sitzen die Hacker? Mitten in so einem Glaspalast in der Mitte der Hauptstadt, irgendwie so am zentralen Platz und haben Spaß und machen da 24 Stunden den Ding und die Kameras berichten.
Das größte aller Gefühle für die US-amerikanischen Hacker ist ja zu Defcon zu gehen oder beim Defcon eine Rede zu halten oder irgend sowas. Und wenn man sich das dann wirklich anschaut, also ich finde das ja kein besonders anstrebenwertes Ziel da quasi, kollektive Besäufnis in Las Vegas, ist vielleicht auch gut, aber quasi so von dem, was das auslösen sollte und kann, da haben sie sich glaube ich dann doch ein bisschen ein Scheibchen abgeschnitten in der europäischen Szene. Es ist ein Summerbreak, ja klar, stimmt natürlich, wenn man sich Defcon und Hope anschaut, dann geht auch eine ganz andere Zielgruppe zu Hope als zu Defcon und bei Defcon geht es halt wirklich nur darum, dass so ein Schwanzvergleich für 15-jährige Hacker.
Also Hope, Hacker is on the planet Earth, quasi der Kongress der 2600er Community.
Quasi, ja. Aber auch das ist, also da finde ich das Beispiel auch schon sehr spannend, also das, was beim CCC in den letzten Jahren noch größer geschrieben wird, also quasi auch andere Leute reinzuholen, das ist ja bei Hope, also beim Hope-Kongress, beim 2600er-Kongress ja auch schon in großen Ansätzen gegeben, da kommt dann halt eben auch Cello Biafra und hält auch politische Rent-Rede zum Beispiel und so, also das, was beim CCC ja schon fast ein bisschen so Standard ist, ist dann dort quasi was Außergewöhnliches eigentlich. Aber naja, da darf man sagen, man darf sich ja nicht auf den eigenen Lorbeeren ausruhen, aber das ist ja wieder eine andere Geschichte.
Ich glaube, gerade auch bei den Kongressen oder Konferenzen sieht man, wie sich doch diese ganze Community untereinander immer wieder was abschaut, die Torcon gab es jetzt doch schon eine Reihe lang, jetzt das erste amerikanische Camp mit dem Torcamp.
Und ich war dort. Ich war dort.
Torstart.
Wie war's? Schön war's. Das Torcamp, wirklich de facto das erste amerikanische Hackercamp, ist jetzt quasi Anfang Juli 2009 abgehalten worden und ich war dort und ich war dann im Endeffekt relativ froh, dass ich mir ein Motelzimmer in so einer 20 Minuten Autoentfernung dann gemietet habe, weil ich beinahe erstickt wäre dort. Es war auf einem alten Titan-1-Missile-Silo-Gelände, war das Ganze. Also so aus den frühen 60er Jahren so ein ICBM-Silo, so ein Intercontinental-Raketen-Silo, der eben quasi eigentlich nur gebaut worden ist, damit die Sowjets die Pläne quasi in die Hand bekommen. Das war so eine ganz interessante Geschichte, wieso diese Dinge überhaupt gebaut worden sind, weil sie eigentlich, wie sie gebaut worden sind, schon längst veraltet waren. Aber da gibt es eine schöne Spionage-Geschichte. Titan-1 im Wikipedia eingeben und ihr wisst es eh alle dann. Titan-1. Und die haben sich halt von der Torcon Foundation, haben sich halt eine Location gesucht, eine Coole, um das erste amerikanische Hackercamp, US-amerikanische Hackercamp abzuhalten und sind auf die Idee gekommen, aha, da mitten im Nichts in Washington State an der Westküste gibt es halt eben diesen Titan-1-Missile-Silo, machen wir doch ein Hackercamp dort. Und das wurde dann auch durchgeführt. Was nicht bedacht wurde, war, dass dort, weil es ja da vor 30 Jahren einen relativ großen Vulkanausbruch dort gab, nämlich Mount St. Helens, dass dort immer noch ein halber Meter vulkanische Asche am Boden rumliegt, der natürlich quasi auf den Feldern nicht ist, weil er in den Feldern gepflügt und in den Boden eingebracht wird, aber auf einem Gelände, wo de facto seit 40, 50 Jahren nichts passiert ist, quasi natürlich die Asche immer noch rumliegt, das haben die Zelter und Zelterinnen feststellen können. Es war sogar so schlimm, dass manche Hacker ihre Notebooks nicht aufgemacht haben, weil sie Angst gehabt haben, dass diese Aschenscheiße in die Notebooks reinkommt. Aber es war wieder auch ein widriger Umstand, muss man sagen, aber es hat wieder schön gezeigt, wie die Szene eigentlich funktioniert und wie man dann zusammenarbeitet und wie man quasi mit dem nicht zu handhabenden Problem des Staubes und der Asche umgeht und da gab es sehr schöne Geschichten, die passiert sind und so und ich bin froh, dabei gewesen zu sein quasi. Es war auf jeden Fall ein guter Start. Es kann auf jeden Fall, vom Wohlgefühl her, kann es noch besser werden, würde ich mal sagen. Aber auch Artein Kaminski und alle miteinander haben ja dann quasi die Losung ausgesprochen, über das Torcamp beschwert, der oder die ist eine Lusche und das war's.
War gut fürs Selbstbewusstsein, oder?
Also es war de facto, also abgesehen davon, die arme Frau, die zehnmal kotzen musste, weil sie einen Hitschlag erlitten hat, ich glaube, man muss sich auch ein bisschen mehr darauf einstellen. Ich glaube, die dachten halt, naja, da fahren wir halt irgendwo hin und da gibt es dann halt Duschen und das und hin und her und sowieso.
Ja, ja, OPR ist nicht ohne, ja.
Vor allem de facto in der Agrarwüste, in der Agrarwüste bei fast 40 Grad Außentemperatur, in seltenen Celsius und so.
Und das für Nerds, die sich sonst in Kellern verstecken und nur bei Nacht rauskommen.
Die sich sonst in Kellern verstecken, naja, sie sind an ihre Grenzen getrieben worden und das ist ja nicht schlecht.
Das ist was Gutes.
Da rede ich, der zwei der vier Nächte im Hotelzimmer verbracht hat, aber.
Jetzt will ich aber noch mal kurz zurückspulen, so auf Ende 2007, Anfang 2008. Du hast ja Astera zusammen mit einigen anderen, also Nick Farr ist ja auch sehr prominent, der immer diese Hackers on a Plane Sachen organisiert, aber ihr habt ja dann verschiedene Talks gehalten über Hackerspaces. Jens Ohlig war auch immer noch mit dabei, haben wir auch beim letzten Podcast schon genannt, seine schönen Thesen darüber, wie so Hackerspaces funktionieren.
Wie Hackerspaces Design-Pattern.
Design-Pattern, genau, das war auch so ein, wie soll ich sagen, allein die Anstrengung, dass man das Ganze mal formalisiert, hat schon eine Aufmerksamkeit darauf gelenkt, dass das sich hier sozusagen um ein replizierbares Modell handelt oder potentiell replizierbares Modell.
Und dadurch, dass es replizierbar und beschreibbar war, ist es auch berichtet worden, weil sobald es so was wie, sobald es Text über was gibt, kann dieser Text gekopiert und gepastet werden und dadurch entstand natürlich auch eine journalistische Aufmerksamkeit, die vorher damit nichts anfangen konnten und jetzt sie gedacht haben, aha, vielleicht machen wir doch mal was drüber.
Was war denn euer, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Talks es gab, aber es gab so einige, ich hab dann irgendwann den Überblick verloren. Hast du denn noch viele?
Nein, ich zähle nicht mehr. Es waren 16 bis jetzt dieses Jahr, ich hab auch gehört. Dieses Jahr alleine? Die letzten zwölf Monate.
Und was waren die Reaktionen? Also das würde mich mal interessieren. Auf was seid ihr gestoßen, wenn ihr das gemacht habt?
Es sind ja nicht nur die Talks selber. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich glaube ich den ersten Talk darüber gehalten hab, auf The Hope, eben letztes Jahr. Und es war erstaunlich. Wir haben am Ende die Frage gestellt, ob die nicht vielleicht Interessenten quasi in dieser Gruppe an Publikum wären. Und vielleicht sollten die doch einfach mal aufstehen, die das für sich als Interessant empfinden, diese Idee, die vielleicht was gründen wollen.
Also nachdem ihr sozusagen einmal berichtet habt, was es so gab, mit den Pattern.
Genau, was macht denn hackerspaces.org? Oder was machen denn Hackerspaces? Und warum ist das eine gute Idee? Es gab vor allem die Diskussion über, warum gibt es keine Ausrede dafür, keinen hackerspace zu gründen? Das ist Nick Fars primäres Anliegen, Ausreden, Ausräumen. Es war interessant, wie es dann zum question and answers Part gekommen ist. Und gleich, glaube ich, der erste oder zweite, der aufgestanden ist, um eine Frage zu stellen, hat diese Frage nicht mehr ins Podium gerichtet. Sondern er hat sich umgedreht zu den anderen Menschen und gesagt, ja ich bin aus da und dort und das klingt doch super und so was möchte ich machen. Wer ist noch da von dieser Stadt? Und dann ist ein anderer aufgestanden. Und alle danach waren genau dasselbe. Also es haben sich quasi gleich gerutscht. Richtig, richtig. Die Fragen kommen eigentlich nie so sehr bei den Talks auf. Das kommt nachher auf in den Pausen, wo dann jemand kommt und sagt, hey, du hast doch diesen Talk erhalten und ich interessiere mich für diese Idee und ich höre das zum ersten Mal. Es sind wirklich eher die Leute, die das zum ersten Mal hören, als dann, wir haben ja die Mailing-Liste, wir haben einen RC-Channel, hackerspaces.org aufzusetzen, wer ist wir? Wir ist jeder, der sich beteiligen möchte.
Aber du hast das mal losgetreten mit, wer war da noch mit?
Jeder hat so seinen Part übernommen und er tut das immer noch. Ich bin jetzt kein extrem großer Wiki-Verfechter, also ich finde die Idee super und so. Gut, dass wir einen Wiki haben, gut, dass es semantisch ist, aber auskennen durch mich damit nicht. Also ich habe nicht diese irrsinnige Motivation, das jetzt zu warten, tue das ab und an. Aber es wartet sich auf alle anderen. Es gibt einfach Leute, die interessieren sich vor allem dafür und die finden das voll cool, weil sie haben das bei anderen schon mal gemacht oder die machen das für ihren eigenen Hacker-Space auch und die engagieren sich dann in dem Bereich und dann kommt jemand anders und sagt, wir sollten einen Presse-Text aufsetzen und ich fange da mal an und so vereinen sich all diese Fähigkeiten wie in einem tatsächlichen Hacker-Space eigentlich wieder auf dieser Plattform, wo jeder von einem anderen Background herkommt.
Ihr habt eigentlich nur die Fackel hochgehalten, habt gesagt, es gibt Hacker-Spaces und man braucht die auch und ihr wollt es auch.
Richtig, es ist mir so zu zeigen, diese Idee ist nichts Neues, es gibt schon so und so viele und wir haben da ja diese hübsche Map, diesen Plan auf der List of Hacker-Spaces, der ganz schön voll ist. Ja, mittlerweile, aber wie wir angefangen haben, vor allem dadurch, dass wir selbst all diese Hacker-Spaces eingetragen haben und so Leute angeschrieben, kennst du noch einen irgendwo, können wir dir reichen, waren es 67, glaube ich, wie ich das erste Mal gezählt habe und jetzt vor etwa sechs Wochen, glaube ich, habe ich die letzte Mal so die Statistik angeschaut und 200 aktive Hacker-Spaces sind gelistet, 167.
Und weltweit, also von irgendwie Nordamerika bis Australien, Asien.
Wo man vorher einfach diesen fetten, schwarzen, diesen Google Pinpoint-Fleck gesehen hat.
Dieser Fleck aus Google-Kärtchen, war halt in Europa halt ganz klassisch.
Deutschland ganz stark und dann so vereinzelt dienen in Nordamerika. Und das war es dann auch schon wieder ziemlich und mittlerweile im letzten Jahr Südafrika. Jemand aus Südafrika hat mich angeschrieben und mir gesagt, er hat den Talk gesehen auf der HOPE. Er war natürlich nicht dort, sondern er hat sich die Videos nachher angeschaut, die Aufnahmen und hat das gesehen und ist drauf gekommen, dass es genau was er möchte. Und offensichtlich hat er völlig unabhängig davon einen Monat vorher einen Blogpost geschrieben. Mittlerweile hat man ja diese wunderbaren Web 2.0 Möglichkeiten, um Leute zu vereinen. Er hat einen Blogpost geschrieben und wusste nicht wirklich, wie er das betiteln soll, aber er wollte eben keinen Co-Working-Place, sondern so einen Co-Exploration-Place, wo man sich Hardware anschaut und gemeinsam ein bisschen programmieren kann in der Freizeit. Und auf diesen Blogpost haben sich auch einige gemeldet, aber gar nicht mal so viele. Und dann hat er den revidiert und nochmal über Hackerspaces geschrieben, so verlinkt. Und auf einmal hat sich eine Gruppe gefunden von 25 Leuten innerhalb von zwei Wochen.
Also es scheint da wirklich ein sehr befreienes Moment dabei zu sein. Ich hatte jetzt auch zufällig eher ein paar Sorgen.
Ein Infrastrukturprovider braucht es natürlich immer und hackerspaces.org ist im Wesentlichen so eine Art Infrastrukturprovider für die Information.
Ich glaube, was wir im Moment am meisten providing, gerade für die Staaten, sind Ratschläge für, wie denn das legal zu gestalten ist. Wie findet man am besten einen Space und welche Rechtsgrundform sollte der haben?
Aber nochmal kurz zur Motivation, was ich aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung gehabt habe. Wir haben die Splinkenlights in Toronto gemacht, da war ich selber das erste Mal in Kanada. Hab dann so, bis wir das Projekt gestartet haben, zwei Besuche dort gehabt. Beim ersten Mal kam ich an, bin halt beim alten Hackerfreund, der da wohnt, aufgeschlagen und fragte halt so, naja, wie sieht es denn aus und so, gibt es denn hier immer so ein Hackerspace? Und er meinte so, ah nee, sowas haben wir hier nicht und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das hier irgendwie großfruchten könnte und hier ist irgendwie alles so verloren und hier gibt es irgendwie eigentlich, naja, wir haben so ein paar Freunde und da treffen wir uns und so. Und ich dachte mir so, schade eigentlich, denk doch mal drüber nach, so. Dann war ich irgendwie zwei Monate später, das zweite Mal da und dann berichtete er mir so, ach ja, übrigens, wir haben gerade einen Mietvertrag untergeschrieben. Wo dann irgendwie letztlich, also der Space heißt hacklap.to, draus herauskam so und dann haben wir halt so über Blinkenlights auf einmal so andere Leute getroffen, die dann auch Teil des Projektes wurden, die die aber sozusagen gar nicht kannten. Dann haben wir die irgendwie gleich zusammengesteckt und derjenige, der dann sozusagen von mir indirekt dann sozusagen dieses Projekt geführt wurde, der war so, wie soll ich sagen, also der war auf einmal durchflutet von so einer Dankbarkeit, also nicht mir gegenüber, sondern diesem Ort gegenüber, da habe ich jetzt schon meine ganze Jugend über drauf gewartet, dass es endlich mal so einen Ort gibt, wo ich irgendwie Leute finde, die einfach genauso drauf sind wie ich. Ich meine, das will natürlich jeder haben, aber eben dann auch speziell mit diesem Ding im Kopf, dass man einfach die ganze Zeit so Ideen hat und basteln will und das vor allem auch teilen will, dieses Wissen. Das war für ihn sehr entscheidend und hat dann einfach gleich vom Start weg angefangen, Vorträge zu halten und das war dann irgendwie so eine ganz wichtige Erfüllung.
Und das hängt natürlich auch vom Mindset auch ein bisschen ab. Also ich habe über Hackerspaces einen Vortrag gehalten auf der e-Tech-Konferenz jetzt im März 2008. Das ist von O'Reilly. Und da sind natürlich die Fragen anders und da funktioniert es natürlich anders, weil da gehen natürlich interessierte Leute dorthin, aber die haben alle natürlich O'Reilly, man muss keine Ahnung, 1000 Dollar Eintritt zahlen und so. Die haben alle so natürlich so ein Business-Hintergedanken dabei und so. Und da war es dann so, dass die Fragen ganz interessant waren, also und da das Konzept zum Teil einfach schwer vermittelbar war, außer quasi, ja ja, da ist ein Raum, da treffen wir uns, da arbeiten wir an Projekten und dann war die Frage gleich, aha, ich verstehe, ein Start-up. Und ich sag, nee, kein Start-up, kein Start-up, ein sozialer Start-up, ein linksozialer Start-up, nee nee nee nee, pfui pfui, nicht diese Sachen in den Mund nehmen. Und es war schwierig dann quasi manchen Leuten dort beizubringen, wie sowas funktionieren kann, ohne einen klassischen ökonomischen Hintergedanken. Und das war spannend für mich festzustellen, also wie das Konzept manchmal einfach quasi schwer vermittelbar ist für Leute, die halt auch dieses Geld im Kopf haben und die quasi aus einer vollkommen anderen Kultur stammen. Also da hat man ja quasi zusammengefasst die ganze Debatte über Copyright quasi in einem Satz quasi. Also Leute, die die Grenzen nicht aus dem Kopf rauskriegen und die, die das gemeinsame quasi einfach nicht verstehen oder nicht verstehen wollen.
Oder nie erlebt haben einfach. Ich mein, gegeben dem, wo man aufwächst, kriegt man das vielleicht gar nicht mit als seine.
Option, was man wählen könnte. Es gibt eine Mailing-Liste, es gibt dieses Wiki, es gibt, glaube ich, auch noch einen Blog.
Richtig, es gibt einen Blog, den wir gerade im Moment sehr vernachlässigt. Das ist ein Aufruf an alle Hörer von CRE. Falls irgendwer mit dem Blog schreiben möchte, dann ist das für jeden offen, genau wie das Wiki.
Vielleicht gibt es nichts zu berichten.
Es gibt eine Menge zu berichten. In Wirklichkeit stapeln sich bei mir die Eingänge von könntet ihr mal darüber schreiben, darüber schreiben, aber keine Zeit zu schreiben. Das ewige Trauerspiel.
Also mittlerweile ist es auch gut und deswegen soll es ja auch nicht so zentralistisch werden mit hackerspaces.org. Die Leute haben ihre Möglichkeiten, die Leute haben ihr Blog, die sollen quasi ihre Meinungen hinschreiben und ihre Ideen und ihre Ansichten und ihre Wünsche und das einfach verbreiten. Also es reicht ja quasi als Hinweis, hey, es gibt hackerspaces.org und da schaut mal hin und da könnt ihr auch eben Wiki eintragen und das und das und das und das und das reicht ja eigentlich. Man muss ja nicht sowas wie das online-wired-hackerspaces-Bewegung werden. Also das ist ein ganzes Gegenteil eigentlich. Je flacher die Hierarchie bleibt und insofern, es stimmt natürlich, weil du hast dich aufgeregt über meinen Begriff des Dachverbandes, den ich vorher verwendet habe. Aber eigentlich stimmt es eigentlich. Eigentlich ist es ein Dachverband, der sich selbst unter Kontrolle halten muss, um ja nicht ein Dachverband zu werden.
Richtig, es ist ein Flachdachverband.
Ein Flachdachverband, das finde ich richtig.
Es ist aber auch so ein bisschen, es hat auch so ein bisschen was von Jugendherbergs und Wandervögel verband, weil es gibt ja offensichtlich sehr viel Reiseaktivität zwischen diesen Hackerspaces. Das ist zumindest mein Eindruck aus der Ferne. Ich habe in dieser Reiseaktivität jetzt nicht so viel teilgenommen, aber man besucht sich viel.
Gerade nachdem das so extrem jung ist als Bewegung, jetzt international gesehen, versucht natürlich jeder, sich woanders was abzuschauen, oder nicht abzuschauen, sondern was dazuzulernen eher und zu sehen, wie funktioniert es denn bei denen, warum wird bei uns das Geschirr nicht gewaschen, bei denen funktioniert solche ganz, ganz einfachen Fragen. Und da die Leute generell gerne reisen, ist das eine wunderbare Ausrede, mal überall wo hinzukommen, weil man wahrscheinlich in das Hof einzuführen wird.
Da gibt es auch interessante Sachen, man kann das vergleichen auch mit der immer noch existierenden Esperanto-Bewegung ja auch, die ja quasi im Großen und Ganzen, ja quasi, da gibt es Leute, die lernen halt Esperanto, aber die wissen gleichzeitig dadurch, dass sie Esperanto sprechen, dass sie in den Ländern und in den Städten, wo andere Leute sind, die Esperanto sprechen, dann immer auch gleich so quasi so einen Schlafplatz gleich mit haben. Also das ist das wesentliche Element quasi, dass man was weiß, dass man Teil einer gewissen Community ist und darauf zählen kann, dass man wo Unterschlupf findet und dass man wo quasi auch aufgenommen wird und rumgezeigt wird und so.
Man kann man sein, aber das ist sicher nicht der zentrale Punkt dieser Reisen.
Na das natürlich nicht, aber ist schon passiert.
Man ist auf jeden Fall. Also wenn man irgendwie sagt, ich bin ein Damen und Herren unterwegs.
Es geht jetzt auch nicht darum, da muss man bei Jens Ohlig wieder mal hinklopfen und sagen, hey, lest's mir den Ohlig, wo drin steht ja auch, dass Hackerspaces ja eigentlich keine Schlafstätten sein sollten. Nein, nein, nein, nein, wir reden ja von Mitgliedern. Aber nun ist es klar zu sagen, aber es organisiert sich was um diese Zentren, also um diese dezentralen Zentren, die sich da bilden.
So funktioniert das ja auch mit Hackers on a Plane, wenn die mal durch die deutschen Hackerspaces reisen, dann schlafen sie irgendwo aufgeteilt bei den Chormitgliedern, wo man die ganzen Hacker-Spaces.
Tja, wälzt man langsam Zeit, auch für die europäischen Hacker mal eine Flugreise zu organisieren, oder?
Ich bin da so ein bisschen am Denken.
Tim, du könntest deine Wiki-Seite anrichten und den Link auf die Mailing-Liste posten. Vielleicht ergibt sich da noch eine Diskussion.
Ich mach da noch ein bisschen Spaß.
Was es jetzt interessanterweise gibt, und das darf man natürlich auch nicht vergessen, Spaces können ja so oder so ausschauen. Also David Dempsey zum Beispiel plant jetzt gerade gemeinsam mit TalkBot Vienna, wo ich auch drin stecke. Also wir arbeiten da an einem mobilen Hacker-Space in Wien und der sich dann auch quasi ausbreiten soll jenseits von Wien.
Was heißt das im Auto?
Die Grundidee ist, einen Hackbus anzuschaffen. David Dempsey hängt genau in diesem Moment quasi, glaube ich, an vier oder fünf Aktionen dran im Internet und versucht, einen schönen Bus zu bekommen. Und die Idee ist natürlich auch, mit diesem Bus dann vielleicht gleich nächste Woche bei Har anzutanzen. Du weißt, dass die Geschichte sich jetzt wiederholt. Die Geschichte wiederholt sich sowieso. Na ist sehr klar. Das Hackmobil. Du weißt, wovon ich rede. Ja, ich weiß.
Das war so das, womit der Club irgendwie bei dem ersten Holland-Camp seiner Zeit aufgeschlagen hat. Genau.
Die Idee ist natürlich, man entwickelt sich natürlich auch weiter, dass dieser Hacker-Bus quasi so ein mobiler Hackspace sein soll, der so ein Zentrum bilden soll, auch für so Workshop-Geschichten. Also wo man dann natürlich, vielleicht wird es irgendwann einmal in jedem mittleren Dorf ein Hackspace geben. Keine Ahnung, ob das dann gut oder schlecht wäre.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Säquivalenz zur fahrbaren Bäckerei, ja? Genau.
Genau so ist es. Essen auf Rädern für Hackerinnen und Hacker. Mobiler Hackbedarf, zack und wenn die blöden Klagenfurter, also das ist jetzt ein Beispiel, sind nicht blöd, wenn die halt keinen Hackspace, also ich darf das ja aus Österreich ja wirklich sagen, also wenn die blöden Klagenfurter keinen Hackspace zusammen bekommen, dann muss halt der Hackbus mal hinfahren, sozusagen, und dort was anbieten. Also das ist einmal die Idee. Genau.
Das ist so wie ja Nothilfe, Erdbebenfall und so weiter, da muss man dann einfach hin und Zelte aufbauen und so.
Ja und was man natürlich nicht vergessen darf, und da ist auch der DVD-M sehr stark hinterher, und was natürlich eine ganze andere Ebene noch aufwirft, es gibt viele Leute, also es gibt viel Hacking-Bedarf und viel, wie ich sagen, Leer- und Spielbedarf, natürlich gerade auch natürlich auch für Kinder. Also wenn man bedenkt, wie viele Zehnjährige da draußen sind, die sich quasi danach sehnen, einfach einen Ort zu haben, wo sie auch was machen können, wo sie quasi spielerisch mit Wissenschaft und Technik und weiß Gott was umgehen können, jenseits dieser klassischen Möglichkeiten, die man halt hat oder eigentlich nicht hat als Kind, also die Ebene kommt auch dazu. Und der DVD-M ist ja besonders hinterher, auch Workshops für Kinder anzubieten und das schon quasi die nächste Generation...
Die nächste Generation hat so einen großen Bus, wo dann auch 20 Leute sitzen.
Wir wissen es doch nicht, mehr oder weniger unser Wohnwagen, großen Bus.
Ja, das hatten wir schon mal mit dem Hackmobil, da kann ich sagen...
Ich glaube, es wird ein bisschen größer als ein Wohnwagen sein.
Aber man muss da nämlich schon ähnliche Qualitäten haben, glaube ich. Also es muss jetzt mal nur so aus der eigenen Erfahrung heraus, so ein kleiner Wohnwagen, naja, da wohnt sich es nicht gut drin.
Na ja, es geht auch nicht ums Wohnen, es geht damit, dorthin zu fahren, den Ball dorthin auszuziehen, dort eine…
Ja, aber die Wohnlichkeit eines Hackerspaces, denke ich, erstreckt sich auch auf das, hast du halt von vornherein einen größeren Bus. Klar, das ist natürlich gleich wieder das andere Problem mit Führerschein und Transportmöglichkeiten und so weiter, aber ich sage nur, der Platz könnte unter Umständen auch entscheidend sein. Und wer weiß, vielleicht haben wir dann irgendwann so ein Konvoi von Hackerbussen, die dann so eine FN24-7-Grundversorgung über die Autobahnnetze Europas strömen.
Dann könnten wir uns vielleicht besser so einen Zugwagon nehmen.
Oh ja, der Hack-Trade, das wurde auch schon mehrfach überlebt. Gab es ja schon mal zu hell, gab es ja tatsächlich zumindest so ein Anreiseprojekt, aber das ist natürlich schwierig, weil teuer und logistisch.
Na ja, quasi die Logistik des Bahnnetzes, das ist ja schon sehr close to us, würde ich mal sagen.
Na ja, mal gucken, wenn noch mehr Stricken geschlossen werden, dann kann man dann vielleicht auch mal mit so einer Hack-Dreisine unterwegs sein. Das wäre dann vielleicht so die Low-Cost-Variante.
Aber wo ich eigentlich noch einhaken wollte, ist, wie Dave eigentlich zu diesem Hackbus gekommen ist. Und er wollte damals schon, ich kann mich erinnern, als wir lange über Hackerspaces geredet haben, wie die Bewegung größer und stärker geworden ist. Und was er immer machen wollte, war Kinder unterrichten. Er hat ja selbst auch zwei Kinder, die sich offensichtlich sehr gut anstellen, so mit Technik und allem. Und er wollte irgendwie sich überlegen, wie denn das Schulsystem quasi ausbaubar wäre in einer Richtung, wo Kinder gleich einmal von voran mit Technologien in Kontakt gebracht werden und halt selber herumtüfteln können in einem einigermaßen sicheren Rahmen und löten lernen, so was. Und das ist mit ein Grund dafür, dass diese Hack-Bus-Idee überhaupt geboren wurde, dass man quasi einen Bus hat, da packt man alles rein, was man so braucht. Eine Loot-Station und bla, und dann fährt man mal in irgendeine Stadt, die eine Schule hat, die sich ja noch nie einen mehr weiter gebildeten Werklehrer gesehen hat und dann packt man dort seine Station aus und macht mal zwei Tage Nachmittags-Programm für die Schülchens und das ist...
Es gibt eine unglaublich lange To-do-Liste für den Hack-Bus. Auf jeden Fall. Für alles. Da stehen 50 Projekte drauf, die mit dem Hack-Bus realisiert werden müssen und da klopfe ich gleich wieder bei Olig an, zuerst mal den Bus kaufen und dann die Projekte machen.
Lies den Olig. Aber dann blicken wir doch mal vielleicht nicht ganz so in die ferne Zukunft, sondern vielleicht mal auch in die unmittelbare, die zum Zeitpunkt der Ausstrahlung dieser Sendung bereits Vergangenheit ist. Dieses Wochenende steht ja hier auch Veranstaltungstätigkeit an. Astera, du bist ja jetzt sozusagen von einem Szene fremden Menschen jetzt schon zum Veranstaltungsorganisator aufgestiegen.
Die PlumberCon findet statt. Das ist offensichtlich, habe ich mir sagen lassen in der Hacker-Konferenz. Es hat ja alles angefangen mit einem großen Scherz, als wir auf der SchmooCon waren.
Was offensichtlich dein Name ist, meinst du?
Dass es angefangen hat mit einem Scherz. Wir waren alle auf der SchmooCon bei Nick Farr zu Besuch. Nick Farr wohnt da gleich gegenüber von Hack-DC, von einem Hackerspace-State, der in einer Kirche untergebracht ist.
In einer Episkopalen. Und ich habe sie schon entweilt. Ich habe dort schon eine Performance gehalten und habe mich sehr gefreut. Meine erste Performance in meinem Leben.
Ich dachte, du hättest sie mit der großen Party entweilt, die wir im Pfarrer-Seil hatten.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich bin da aufgetaucht mit dem großen Politismus-Banner und habe die anderen Götter reingeholt. Ich glaube, das mag der eine Gott am wenigsten, wenn die anderen Götter dazukommen.
Wo du doch an gar keiner glaubst.
Das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Wir haben quasi seine Wohnung zu neun invaded und wir hatten dann gewisse Probleme mit dem Abfluss sowohl in der Küche als auch in der Toilette. Als Nick die ganzen Hacker gerade zum Flughafen gebracht hat, dachte ich mir, ich räume hier mal hübsch auf. Meine weiblichen Gefühle haben da ein bisschen durchgeschlagen erstaunlicherweise. Schau, dass es nachher wieder halbwegs ausschaut wie vorher. Ich finde die Toilette überschwemmt, nachdem vorher schon mal eben die Küche überschwemmt. Interessant. Ich als Nicht-Amerikanerin gehe halt so an den Chemiekasten und suche mir eine Flasche heraus, die offensichtlich ein Abflussreiniger ist. Das Kleingedruckte habe ich nicht gelesen, nur die Dosisierung, die habe ich schon nur halbiert. Und das Kleingedruckte hätte dann eigentlich gesagt, das kann man für alles verwenden und nicht für Internetten. Tja, das war dann noch schlimmer und der Quark kam zurück.
Was ist mit dem Quark passiert?
Ja, es hat sich nichts gelöst. Du leerst es einfach ins Wasser und lässt es runter, theoretisch sollte das helfen. In dem Falle, eine Toilette hilft das nicht, wahrscheinlich weil die Rohre...
Aber ist jetzt nicht irgendwie explodiert aufgeschäumt oder so?
Es ist nicht explodiert, aber ich kann mir sagen, dass eine Toilette wurde ausgeschäumt.
Weil sie dann aufgefressen wurde von diesem Quark oder was?
Ich kann es nicht sagen. Sie hat dann wieder ein wenig funktioniert, wie wir das Appartement verlassen haben am nächsten Tag. Aber ja, großes Fail, großes Fail. Es gibt eine neue. Aber ja, Nick Farr kommt zurück mit einem anderen kanadischen Hacker und sie sagen so zu mir, ich sollte mal weniger auf all den internationalen Kongressen herumopsen und mal lieber zu einem Plumbing-Kongress gehen. Also für die Installature. Ja, richtig. Und so kam irgendwie die Plumber-Commerce auf und wieder so ist. Und wenn man sonst nichts zu tun hat als Nord, macht man dumme Scherze über das Internet. Und da war natürlich so eine Analogie nicht fern wie... Ja, die Internet-Series of tubes oder ob nicht, wenn wir eine Plumber-Con abhielten, ob da nicht möglicherweise Jay Gaplebaum einen Talk halten könnte über The Cold Poop Attack oder die wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz schlechten Scherze. Und weil alles schon so lustig war, habe ich beschlossen, ich trage das in die Außenwelt, wo ich das immer mache, so auf Twitter und so und berichte darüber, dass diese Konferenz stattfinden wird und erstaunlich. Also für mich war das alles ein Scherz und ich habe die Website dazu gemacht, die furchtbar war, ganz statisch furchtbar, weil war ja eh wurscht, ist eben ein Scherz. Und dann kamen die ersten Submissions. Und nach zwei Wochen habe ich dann einsehen müssen, dass das eine Konferenz ist.
Sind irgendwelche Submissions wirklich spezifisch über Plumbing gekommen?
Ja, es kamen welche. Nick Farr, das ist eine lustige Geschichte, kam in Wien an und war erstaunt, dass das keine LoL-Konferenz ist. Der war sich nicht der Sache bewusst, dass wir da tatsächlich einige Exploits besprechen, dass wir da über Forensics reden, dass wir da über alle möglichen Arten reden, wie man so sein Botnetz aufbaut oder nicht.
LoL-Konferenz müssen wir jetzt auch nochmal kurz erläutern. Das sind so die Konferenzen, die sich sozusagen mehr so dem lustigen kulturellen Teil des Internets widmen. Also was gibt's da, Roffelkorn gibt's, glaube ich. Ja, da spielt also diese ganze Memewelt mit rein, die wir hier schon mal bei CAE 121 ausführlich besprochen haben. Ja, ist also keine, sondern ist alles total ernst.
Nein, es ist nicht so, dass das alles total ernst ist. Ich wurde ja ein paar Mal gefragt und habe dann schon auch Leuten zugesprochen, doch die eine oder andere I Can Has Cheeseburger Grafik mit einzunehmen in ihrer Präsentation. Nur mal so zur Auflockerung dazwischen. Aber es sind doch tatsächlich Themen, die die Bevölkerung möglicherweise interessieren und die ihr Interesse erweitern sollen. Ich persönlich interessiere mich jetzt mehr so für den Security-Bereich, aber ja, das Interesse ist eigentlich sehr weit gestreut. Aber diese Konferenz sollte nicht spezifisch jetzt nur Hacking im engsten Sinne umfassen, sondern wir haben angestrebt, einfach eine Menge Workshops zu haben an einem Tag und dann Talks auf dem anderen Tag und möglichst nicht in einem thematischen Bereich zwei Speaker zu haben, sondern einfach von allem ein bisschen was, sodass jeder vielleicht seinen Horizont ein wenig erweitern kann und sich dann selbst vertreten.
Und das ist eigentlich, wenn man das wieder so sagen kann, eigentlich im besten amerikanischen Kons-Sinne, also eigentlich ist BlumbergCon der erste amerikanische europäische Hacker-Con, weil sozusagen diese Kon-Welt ist ja was sehr US-amerikanisches. Der Chaos-Computer-Kongress ist eigentlich kein Kon, das ist irgendwie was anderes und so.
Ist ein Kongress.
Ist ein Kongress, aber kein Kon.
Mehr ein Parlament als...
Aber das große Vorbild der BlumbergCon. Also in den Staaten gibt es halt diese lange Tradition der Cons, wo quasi echt in jedem, weißt du was, in Louisville, Kentucky gibt es irgendeinen Hacker-Con und so und da kommen dann natürlich dann nur 100 Leute hin oder sowas, die im Bereich sind. Das finde ich aber nicht unspannend, weil das einfach so lokale Mikrokonferenzen sind für Hacker.
Ich gucke gerade aufs Programm und sehe gerade ja, dass du das Toiletten-Thema schaffst, aber dann tatsächlich. Und zwar interessanterweise ist es dann auch ein Beitrag von dem mir schon erwähnten Toronto Hack Lab. Die haben ja ihre Toilette an Twitter angeschlossen.
Ja, ich habe ihn gebeten, da unbedingt mal einen Talk zu machen und aufzunehmen, weil das ist halt das andere. Jetzt haben wir da so eine kleine Mini-Con. Und woher nehmen wir das Geld, um Speaker einzufliegen? Das gibt es einfach nicht. Dementsprechend im besten Internet-Sinner lassen wir Leute sich hinein verbinden und displayen sie auf einer Leinwand. Das sind einfach Remote-Gehaltenden-Talks. Damit wir jetzt nicht einfach auf wirklich interessante Themen verzichten müssen, bloß weil wir den Speaker jetzt nicht haben können. Warum denn nicht? Du hast trotzdem die Interaktion. Die Leute können immer noch Fragen stellen. Es ist besser, als sich das Video auf YouTube anschauen.
Die Absätze sind natürlich auch zeitlich verbunden, muss man dazu sagen, mit der HA, dem holländischen Open Air Camp, was nächste Woche ist.
Fast hätte ich das selbe Wochenende gelegt, wenn ich so chaotisch bin.
Aber so ist doch eigentlich ganz praktisch, weil hier schon so ein großer Schub an gerollt kommt.
Das ist richtig. Das erfordert viel Freinehmen und so, aber dass es schon mal einfacher gewesen ist, beteilen sie jetzt auch sehr oft. Yes, das ist Hadi's Toilettenbots, der an Twitter tweetert. Wie sagt man?
Er twitter-tweets.
Er twitter-tweets mit Twitter.
Ist alles noch nicht festgeschrieben, wenn man das so vom linguistischen Schampengas macht. Das ist gerade zu der Stadt. In ein, zwei Jahren, wenn es dann im Duden drinsteht, dann wies man es.
Du könntest das überhört twitteren, dann ist es im Internet, dann ist es wahr. Aber das können wir auch nach.
Da kriege ich keine Luft, muss ich euch ja auch sagen.
Ich wollte jetzt auch den Bogen mal wieder zurückschlagen. Oder wolltest du zu dieser Toilette noch was erzählen?
Auf jeden Fall. Das Coole, was mich an diesem Projekt jetzt extrem fasziniert hat, ist nicht, man hat jetzt einen Arduino irgendwo angehängt in einer Toilettspülung, der mit ein paar Sensoren sieht. Der, der sich jetzt anschaut, hat gerade wer runtergelassen, hat jemand die Toilette betreten oder verlassen, ist eine gewisse Überschwemmung am Boden, alles Sensoren, die er noch einbauen wollte.
Wissen Sie, mit Kloteckl rauf und runter?
Ja, diesen Sensoren wollte er auch einbauen. Hatte er noch nicht.
Ach so, das Ding wird sozusagen voll vernetzt?
Genau, je nachdem.
Aber was meinst du mit runtergelassen? Ob die Hose runtergelassen wurde oder was?
Nein, ob das Wasser runtergespült wurde. Das interessante daran war ja, welche Probleme er da irgendwie encountered hat.
Netzwerk, Switch-mäßige Natur. Ich glaube, die Toilette ist jetzt gerade, er hat gerade getwittert, glaube ich, dass die Toilette jetzt auf dem Cover der aktuellen Weiheit gelandet ist.
Großartig. Ich bin begeistert.
Das hat er irgendwie gestern getwittert.
Sie war ja auch auf Slash-Date.
Gut, zurück zu den Hackerspaces. Soweit ist das jetzt nicht entfernt, weil ich denke auch, dass das hängt ja auch alles sehr eng miteinander. Nicht wahr? Also Konferenzen, dieses gegenseitige Besuchen. Wenn man eh schon zusammen ist, dann kann man sich auch gleich noch was erklären. Dann eben diese Hackerspaces. Was auf einmal entsteht, ist eine interessante, globale Infrastruktur von Leuten, wo sich Leute treffen, die einfach Bock haben, kreativ zu sein und die auch vor allem Bock haben, ihr Wissen weiterzugeben und sich in Kommunikation zu begeben. Denkst du, um sich auszutauschen. Und das ist jetzt schon alles sehr weit. Jetzt hattest du, Johannes, da neulich einen Text, das ist ja schon angerissen, ein Manifest geschrieben.
Ein Pamphlet, würde ich so sagen, literarisch ist das korrekt.
Was dann auch entsprechend Ärgernis erzeugt hat, wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, auf der Mailing-Liste. Warum?
Okay, also ihr habt gemeinsam mit dem Frank A. Schneider, der auch ein Monochrom-Mitglied ist, geschrieben und entstanden ist quasi der Wunder.
Monochrom-Kultur.
Jaja, genau. Und wir haben den Text deswegen geschrieben, weil wir so ein halbes Jahr vorher, also im halben Jahr, bevor wir den Text verfasst haben, mit unterschiedlichen Leuten gequatscht haben, aus unterschiedlichen Hackerspaces und unterschiedlichen Bereichen, uns da immer wieder, ist ja klar, es immer wieder auch Klagen gibt. Oder irgendwie, wir sagen, irgendwas funktioniert nicht so gut. Oder wir haben uns ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht, wo kommen denn diese Beschwerden her? Oder was ist das? Oder jenseits von, da wird nicht abgespült, in der Küche oder so. Also es gibt Leute, auch Asietl zum Beispiel, habe ich da mit jemandem gesprochen und so, die hat, also sie hat eigentlich fast eine Stunde quasi sich ausgeheult über das, und ich habe gesagt, na ist es wirklich so, was ist denn das, was zusammengefasst, was ärgert dich denn? Und das Ärgernis war quasi, es ist so geschlossen. Es ist so geschlossen, das muss offener werden, das muss, das muss, und die Frage war dann, na wenn es aber so, aber das Ding an sich ist ja offen, es kann ja jeder tun, es kann ja jeder und jede quasi ein Hackerspace eröffnen, sofort, jetzt, und es braucht ja auch niemand um Genehmigung fragen oder so, und die richtige Kritik war dann, ja ein offener Raum ist nicht sofort offen, also diese Offenheit, die muss man auch kämpfen und die muss man auch feststellen und die muss man auch wollen.
Also es reicht nicht, die Tür zu öffnen, man muss die Leute auch herein bitten.
Man muss die Leute auch herein bitten. Und ich hab dann einfach mit Frank mich hingesetzt und hab so ein paar von diesen Kritiken, sagen wir mal, aufgeschrieben und analysiert und hab dann quasi so ein politisches Pamphlet dann verfasst, wo eigentlich der Kern, die Kernidee des Textes war, die Leute darauf hinzuweisen, dass in der ganzen Euphorie, man muss immer auch ein bisschen aber sagen können. Also ich bin ja ein großer Fan von Hackerspaces, ich bin Mitglied bei dreien davon, auch zahlendes und bin Geburtshelfer von Noise Bridge und weiß Gott was. Und das heißt jetzt nicht, dass ich quasi da irgendwas schlecht reden will oder so, aber gleichzeitig auch in einer Phase, in der wir jetzt drinstecken, wo quasi innerhalb von einem Jahr 200 weitere Hackerspaces aufpoppen und so, muss man so ein bisschen auch analysieren und schauen, was geht denn da auch falsch und was könnte denn besser sein und so. Und ich bin ja Linker und habe das quasi ein bisschen so in der linken Tradition betrachtet und habe eben diesen Text verfasst, der im Hacking the Spaces heißt, also wo es eigentlich darum geht, wir müssen eigentlich zum Teil auch unsere eigenen Hackerspaces wieder hacken und drüber nachdenken, was da schief läuft und was falsch läuft und was man ändern kann und was die Dinge eigentlich sollen, also was ist eigentlich der Sinn dahinter überhaupt ein Hacker-Space zu haben, jenseits dessen, dass man halt ab und zu mal Lettruis baut oder irgendso was. Und die Feststellung ist, dass die Hacker-Spaces ja quasi eine Tradition haben. Viele Leute wollen das leider nicht wahrhaben und sehen das auch nicht, aber es gibt halt eine Tradition, die 30 Jahre, 40 Jahre zurück reicht. Und Hacker-Spaces stammen quasi eigentlich in der Form, wie sie heute immer noch existieren und wie sie vor allem quasi in Deutschland und Österreich nicht, aber in Deutschland und in den Niederlanden existiert haben, wie aus der Tradition quasi einer gewissen autonomen Bewegung und einer linken widerständigen Bewegung. Also jetzt quasi nicht aus der Bewegung der Hippies, der 60er Jahre, weil das Problem war, dass die Hippies einen viel zu großen Anspruch hatten. Die Hippies haben gedacht, sie können quasi mit ihrem Mantra quasi das Böse wegbeten und das funktioniert halt sozusagen nicht. Was dann in den 70er Jahren passiert ist, ist, dass quasi nachdem diese makropolitische Revolution einfach nicht stattgefunden hat und dass auch nach 1968 die Strukturen nicht umgestürzt werden konnten oder das einfach alles zu stabil war, dass in den 70er Jahren sich die Leute gedacht haben, na komplett assimilieren lassen wir uns auch nicht, wir schaffen uns kleine, freie Räume, über die wir eine gewisse Kontrolle halten können, die von dieser bürgerlichen Bourgeoisen-Kultur sich auch irgendwie abgrenzt und das sind auch so Sachen wie anti-orthäere Kindergärten, genauso wie Squats oder wie freie Piratenradios, aber auch wie Hackerspaces und also abgegrenzte, freie, autonome Räume. Also ich würde mal sagen, die Hochkultur dieser freien, autonomen Räume beginnt ab 1972. Man kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, was definitiv der erste Hackerspace war, aber es gibt so Beispiele wie, naja, der erste Hackerspace ist es unmöglich, das zu sagen. Also man kann nicht wirklich behaupten, dass, wenn wir dabei bleiben, dass wir eigentlich nicht genau wissen, was ein Hackerspace ist, wir haben uns ja vorher bei der Definition selbst schwer getan, kann man eigentlich nur sagen, dass ein Hackerspace ein Raum ist, in dem man zusammenarbeitet, der offen ist, der quasi einen kreativen Umgang mit Technologie, mal sagen, voraussetzt und einen kreativen Umgang mit, auch mit dem Gegenüber und mit den Mitmenschen, was sie voraussetzt. Man kann zum Teil sagen, dass vielleicht, also in Italien gab es eine starke Autonomier-Bewegung in den 70er Jahren, man kann zum Teil sagen, wahrscheinlich sind die ersten Piratenradio-Stationen in Italien bis zu einem gewissen Grad so aktive Hacker-Bastel-Bewegungen.
Ich hatte ja hier auch ein Gespräch zu dieser Geschichte im Prinzip, Chaosradio Express 77 Tuwatt TXT, wo es letztlich darauf hinführte, auf diese Geburtsstunde des Chaos-Computer-Club, dieses Tuwatt-Treffen, dem dann aber eben auch so verschiedene Schritte vorgingen. Und eben auch Mitte der 70er Jahre in Hamburg gab es halt diesen Medienladen, der sich sozusagen gegründet hat, um überhaupt erstmal einen anderen Medienbezug als den der etablierten Massenmedien überhaupt zu ermöglichen, Archiv aufzubauen und so was. Sowas meinst du?
Ja, genau. So was meine ich. Deswegen ist es schwer zu sagen, das ist der erste Hacker-Space, weil wenn man es mit der Definition schon schwer tut, kann man es schwer irgendwo hinzeigen oder so. Aber da gibt es halt diese Bewegung dieser offenen, autonomen Räume, die man sich aber auch quasi erkämpft und sagt, hey, das ist jetzt unser Raum und da herrschen jetzt unsere Regeln und diese Regeln sind auch andere Regeln als die Regeln draußen sozusagen. Auch temporäre. Auch temporäre autonome Zonen, das sind ja alles Konzepte aus den 70er Jahren im Wesentlichen. Und aus dem heraus entsteht natürlich auch so was wie der Chaos-Computer-Club, ist eh klar. Also das sind natürlich alles Vorläufer, Räume und sich treffen und tun. Aber halt so einen gewissen Antagonismus zu haben, zu wissen, wir versuchen das jetzt wirklich de facto anders. Wir können die Welt an sich nicht ändern, komplett, aber wir können uns Freiräume erkämpfen, sozusagen. Also ob es jetzt besetzte Räume sind oder was auch immer, das ist halt eine andere Frage. Aber das würde ich mal sagen, in dem Bereich, da gab es ja auch alternative bäuerliche Kooperationen. Kommunen bis zu einem gewissen Grad gehören da auch rein, aber das sind alles diese Sachen, die in den späten 60er-Jahren, in den 70er-Jahren vor allem passieren, also wo man halt gemerkt hat, man kann es nicht komplett umstürzen. Also 68 ist im Wesentlichen quasi draufgegangen, also was tun wir jetzt? Wir wollen ja trotzdem quasi was verändern können. Naja, versuchen wir es quasi im mikropolitischen Bereich.
Wo ist denn jetzt die Verbindung zu der aktuellen Hackerspace?
Naja, ich sehe im Moment gerade in einer Zeit der Krise, die wir jetzt gerade haben, wo groß geschrien wird, alles bricht und alles muss neu werden und dann wird es ja doch nicht neu, ist es ja sehr spannend zu beobachten, dass gerade in so einer Zeit viele, viele Hackerspaces quasi auftreten. Wir haben da mit Jens Ohle, der auch Proofreader des Manifests quasi war und mit dem ich mit der Fieldtrip diskutiert habe, hat ja auch festgestellt, es ist ja interessant, dass gerade jetzt in einer Zeit, wo viele Leute, wie das so schön heißt, freigesetzt werden in technologischen Firmen oder quasi rausgeschmissen werden und keinen Job haben, ja irgendwo mit ihrem kreativen Output hinwollen oder hin und hin müssen quasi und dass das auch damit zu tun hat, genau in dieser spezifischen Zeit, in der wir jetzt leben, dass viele Hackerspaces auch von dem natürlich profitieren, dass Leute einfach nichts zu tun haben und was tun wollen und aber nicht können und das ist ein wesentlicher Faktor, wieso das gerade so populär ist oder warum das so einen Zulauf hat.
Alle waren weg und steckten in ihren gefüllten Kühlschränken.
Und die prinzipielle Kritik, die wir geäußert haben, ist, dass man das nicht vergessen darf, wo Hackerspaces herkommen. Vor allem, wenn es darum geht, quasi auch quasi den eigenen Drang, dass man trifft sich nur mit Leuten, mit denen man sich auch sicher versteht. Das muss man ein bisschen ablegen, würde ich sagen. Ist eh klar, dass Hackerspaces natürlich aus der Motivation heraus entstehen, dass man gerne mit Leuten, die so sind wie man selbst quasi oder Frau selbst, sehr selten, aber dass man mit denen halt gemeinsam was tut. Man darf aber nicht vergessen, dass, man darf die Tradition nicht vergessen, dass Hackerspaces in der Form und auch so wunderbare Organisationen wie der Chaos Computer Club ja quasi nur deswegen existieren, weil es um eine Abgrenzung ging, auch um auch festzustellen, hey, wir sind eine politische Organisation. Es geht darum, ein Statement zu machen, es geht darum, auch was weiterzubringen und auch in die Zukunft zu denken. Also die Kritik wäre, Hackerspaces sollten mehr sein, als nur rum sitzen und Let-Floes machen und es sollten auch ein gewisses Selbstverständnismuster auch aufgebaut werden, dass man da auch was Aktives, was Wichtiges und auch was Politisches tut. Viele Leute sagen dann gleich, naja, unser Hackerspace ist nicht politisch, da gab es ja die größten Flame Wars, wie ich diesen Text veröffentlicht habe, wir sind doch nicht politisch, warum sollen wir politisch sein? Wir lassen uns doch von euch nicht vereinnahmen, dass wir auf einmal politisch sind. Nein, nein, nein, wir wollen das nicht. Aber man darf die Geschichte nicht vergessen, das kann man nicht einfach ausklammern. Und alleine der Schritt quasi, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen, wie man was zerlegen kann, wie man was neu denken kann, wie man quasi in Open Source und solchen Sachen nachdenkt, das sind alles politische Motivationen. Die Leute vergessen das leider vollkommen manchmal, dass es da schon darum geht, was zu verbessern und um eine bessere Welt, wenn man es pathetisch ausdrücken will, zu schaffen. Und leider ist dieser utopische Gedanke, würde ich mal sagen, wird manchmal einfach vergessen.
Vielleicht ist das ja auch nur eine Übergangsphase, weil ich hab das ja auch so wahrgenommen, dass jetzt gerade die Hackerspaces des CCC wiederum andererseits lange, lange Zeit sehr politisch waren, aber eben einen großen Mangel an diesem Hands-on-Hacking hatten. Das fanden zwar natürlich im einzelnen statt mit dem, was er gemacht hat, aber dass man sich wirklich mal darauf konzentriert, gemeinsame Infrastruktur aufzubauen, sich ein Labor, Maschinen, Bastelkram und so weiter zu schaffen, aufzuhalten und auch explizit Leute anzuziehen, die jetzt nicht unbedingt primär was mit dem politischen Grundhaltung erst anfangen können, sondern die vor allem durch diese Hands-on-Hacking, also einfach wirklich eben genau den unpolitischen Teil, oder den zunächst einmal scheinbar unpolitischen Teil, gibt es auch nichts unpolitisches eigentlich.
Eigentlich muss man so mal beginnen.
Aber wie hast du denn das empfunden, Astera, als du da diesen Text gepostet hast?
Was eigentlich noch fehlt, und das hänge ich jetzt noch dran, ist, dass es ja quasi ein paar Vorschläge eingebettet waren in diesem Ding. Es war quasi nicht nur ein reines Pamphlet, alles ist scheiße und so.
Dann kann ich das ja gleich nochmal angehen, Johannes. Ich wollte mal wissen, was hast du da so gedacht?
Generell, ja, es war lange nichts los auf der Liste. Es sah schon ein bisschen nach einem Flame of a Beginner aus. Nein, das Problem, das ich generell damit hatte, der Text ist großartig, weil er eine Grundlage bietet, eine Basis bietet zur Diskussion und alles, was quasi nichts sagt, so und das ist jetzt unser neues Manifest und wir werden jetzt alle danach handeln, ist eine Basis für eine Diskussion, die einfach ständig geführt werden soll. Weil sonst ändert sich nichts, sonst gibt es keine Zukunft, sonst bleiben wir einfach in der Gegend stecken und können auch schlafen gehen. Ändern wir ja nicht die Welt. Das Interessante fand ich eher, dass offensichtlich auf der Liste nicht mehr sehr viel Übung herrscht. Das bezieht sich nicht nur auf diese Mailing-Liste, sondern wahrscheinlich generell, dass nicht mehr sehr viel Übung herrscht in Diskussionskultur. Und wie man sieht, das so, ich glaube, nach diesem Anmeld von Johannes kamen vier Mails, die tatsächlich valide waren in ihrer Aussage, die interessant waren, die zu dieser Diskussion beigetragen haben. Und dann ist es so abgedriftet in die erste Meterebene. Und von der kommt es dann in mehr Flamer Richtung, in die Meta-Mete-Ebene. Und von der löst sich dann völlig auf, bis dann so Fragen kommen, wie muss diese Liste moderiert werden? Und wer sollte die Moderation übernehmen? Also das sind Sachen, wo ich mir denke, wir sind nicht im Kindergarten. Es müsste möglich sein von erwachsenen Menschen, die sich ja sonst auch über so viele Sachen Gedanken machen, die einfach Sachen durch überlegen und von allen möglichen Seiten betrachten. Warum können die auf einmal Sprache und diese Kommunikation zwischen Menschen nicht mehr genauso analysieren, wie sie einfach technisch das Gerät analysieren? Und es ist einfach etwas, das sie verlernt haben.
An der Stelle greift natürlich Johannes Kritik dann auch gleich wieder.
Es gab viele, viele auch positive Reaktionen, das muss man auch dazu sagen. Es gab viele, viele Blog-Einträge, die gesagt haben, ja, das stimmt eigentlich. Warum bauen die Hacker Lethroys und setzen ihre wunderbaren Dronen, die sie da haben, nicht als Copwatch-Programme ein und weiß Gott was? Es gab aber dann viele, viele gute Reaktionen darauf, was man direkt an Projekten machen könnte, die genau in diese Richtung gehen.
Machen könnte es immer so eine Sache. Das höre ich ja besonders oft. Wir sollten mal, wir könnten mal, man müsste mal. Und das ist dann so eine Sache, wir erhalten ja auch solche Mails mit, ihr solltet mal, wo ich dann gerne zur Antwort schreibe, ja, mach das mal. Das wäre super, das klingt großartig. Genehmigung erteilt. Das ist dieser Do-ism, den neues Bridge decken.
Ja, der Do-ism ist ja super. Und der Do-ism muss natürlich, und der steht auch in dem, in der Santurna. Nein, das ist der, glaube ich, der Prit hat das schon mal wirklich verwendet, glaube ich, als Begriff Do-ism, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Aber ich, Prit, vollkommen, vollkommen egal.
Denismus der Tat sozusagen.
Also was die Leute sagen, also erstens einmal haben sie mit formaler Kritik relativ wenig anfangen können, weil viele Hacker natürlich mit formaler Kritik quasi auch nicht wirklich was anfangen können. Also sagen sie, wie reagiere ich jetzt adäquat auf dieses Pamphlet? Wie schreibe ich da zurück? Also da gab es halt irgendwie ein bisschen auch Probleme, auch in der Lesart, wie soll man das jetzt wahrnehmen? Da kommt jetzt irgendein Typ daher und der scheißt uns jetzt in unsere schöne Bewegung da rein. Und das wollen wir natürlich überhaupt gar nicht und so. Und wir wollen natürlich nicht kritisiert werden. Das Interessante dran ist, und das ist ja auch das, was wir bei Monochrome die ganze Zeit machen, am spannendsten ist die Kritik dann, wenn man wirklich im Endeffekt was verändern kann. Also es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn, zum hunderttausendsten Mal über George W. Bush zu schreien. Wenn nebenan am Tisch irgendein Mädchen sexistisch da belästigt wird, dann geht man natürlich rüber und kümmert sich um das. Das macht mehr Sinn quasi als sich zum hunderttausendsten Mal über George W. Er ist ein Idiot. Aber man kann nichts dran ändern. Das sind systemische Sachen, was sollen wir denn tun? Und das geht's. Zum Beispiel ist es sehr spannend zu betrachten, das steht in diesem Text ja auch drinnen, dass es viele Hackerspaces gibt, also vor allem in Amerika, in US-Amerika, wo es kein einziges schwarzes Mitglied gibt. An solche Fragestellungen geht's natürlich auch. Also inwieweit sind diese Spaces so offen, wenn man dann doch nur am kleinen Freundeskreis klebt? Und da brauchen wir uns quasi in Europa auch nichts groß an die Fahnen schreiben. Ich muss einmal fragen, wie viele nordafrikanische Hackerspace-Mitglieder es gibt oder wie viel der Frauenanteil in Hackerspaces in Europa ist. Und das sind Sachen, das ist immer sehr ernst, dass man über das reden sollte, weil es geht ja darum, quasi die Welt zu verändern und die Welt zu verbessern. Und da muss man auch ein bisschen einen Outreach machen sozusagen, weil es ist eh klar und es sind natürlich bis zu einem gewissen Grad exkludierende Witze und das und hin und her, aber man muss, und im MetaLab funktioniert das manchmal auch recht gut, dann einfach Leute mitbringen. Schaut euch das MetaLab an, wie es da funktioniert. Ich weiß, ein paar Leute da drin sind ein bisschen komisch, aber da geht es auch um einen Annäherungsprozess. Und das darf man nicht vergessen. Also man darf sich nicht auf den Lorbeeren ausruhen, dass man halt da diesen schönen Raum hat und da treffen wir uns halt mit all unseren Freunden und wir verstehen denselben Witz und wir kennen alle Lolcats und bla bla bla und so wie so. Da muss man auch ein bisschen aktiv rausgehen und die Leute einladen, auch im Sinne eines schönen radikalen Inklusionismus, wie es zum Beispiel Noisebridge betreibt. Noisebridge ist ein extrem gutes Beispiel, wo das wirklich gut klappt, wo niemand quasi deswegen herausgeschmissen wird, weil nein, das interessiert uns jetzt nicht. Das ist nicht der Platz dafür, um über das zu reden. Das gibt es einfach in Noisebridge nicht. Und das sieht man dann auch interessanterweise daran, wie viele Frauen dort Mitglieder sind, wie viele Latinos, die als Mitglieder haben, was ja quasi in der amerikanischen Gesellschaft ja Wahnsinn ist. Es gibt, die Latinos sind ja mittlerweile keine Minderheit mehr. Das ist ja quasi, die sind ja auch schon zur politischen Kraft geworden.
Und in Kalifornien ist es natürlich noch ganz anders.
Und da muss man mal schauen, wie viele Clubs und Spaces und Workshops und Co-Working Spaces es gibt, wo überhaupt ein Latino-Mitglied da drin sitzt. Und im Noise-Bridge ist das relativ ausgeglichen. Es sind keine 50-50% oder so, aber es findet statt. Und sie sind sich über dessen auch bewusst. Und eigentlich geht es in dem Pamphlet darum, den Leuten quasi ein bisschen ins Gewissen zu reden und Bewusstsein zu streuen, dass die Sachen sind cool, die wir tun, aber sie könnten noch viel, viel cooler sein.
Was ich mir halt denke, was in dem Pamphlet jetzt so nicht drin steht, aber was durchaus beeinflusst hat, dass wir darüber so ad hoc eine Diskussionsrunde gemacht haben beim HSF, beim Hackerspace-Fest in Vitry-sur-Seine, in der Nähe von Paris, das immer im Templab abgehalten hat. Templab, der Name deshalb, weil sie ja...
Der Helekin war das doch, der Helekin hat das doch organisiert, oder?
Richtig, das war viel mit Helekin, mit Jaromir mit mir.
Genau, genau. Weil die waren ziemlich aktiv in der Diskussion auf der Hackerspaces-Liste, da gab es ja glaube ich zwei Mails. Und die waren da sehr, sehr interessiert in der Diskussion und wollten das ja weiterführen.
Auf jeden Fall, vor allem weil Jaromir ja sich selbst auch als ein Vertreter sieht für die ganzen südeuropäischen Hackerspaces, die vor allem in Italien, in Spanien, die wirklich autonome Räume sind, besetzte Häuser, richtige.
Der ist ja auch schon seit Ewigkeiten dabei.
Richtig und lebt jetzt seit einiger Zeit in Amsterdam. Kommt morgen an.
Ich habe ihn ja noch nie persönlich getroffen.
In der Diskussionsrunde war es mir ein besonderes Anliegen, dass man jetzt an diesen Text irgendwie anknüpft, den du geschrieben hast oder an sowas wie die Hackerspace Design Patterns generell an all dem, was wir an Unterlagen quasi haben, wo wir so ein bisschen Selbstfindungsdefinitions-Ding drin haben. Und dass wir uns überlegen, die Tatsache, dass jedes Mal, wenn irgendein Hackerspace-Member offensichtlich gefragt wird zu deren politischer Positionierung, dass sie dann gleich so die Politik, das ist offen, da lassen wir uns nicht drauf ein, da soll jeder machen, was er möchte, wir haben da keine offizielle Stellungnahme dazu. Weil jeder immer gleich so offiziell nicht von sich aus redet, sondern für den Hackerspace, dem er angehört. Die Sache ist, dass es ja weniger darum geht, wie ist die politische Ausrichtung von diesem Hackerspace jetzt in diesem Moment. Der muss sich nicht dafür interessieren, er kann sich dafür interessieren, die Member können alle verschiedene Interessen haben, das macht ja keinen Unterschied. Die Sache ist, dass sie sich dadurch, dass sie dem so oppositioniert gegenüberstehen, so mit Politik, na na fragt mich nicht, weil es gibt nichts Offizielles, dass sie sich auch nicht überlegen, welchen Einfluss nimmt denn eine solche Bewegung, die halt doch wirklich anständig groß ist, kann man sagen, auf lokale Politik und irgendwo, richtig. Und irgendwo dann irgendwann einmal auch auf internationaler Politik. Weil es ist eine Bewegung, die verstärkt wird durch die momentane, ökonomische Situation. Und die diese dann auch weiterhin beeinflusst, je stärker die Bewegung wird. Ich meine, das ist ein ständiges Einfluss nehmen aufeinander und ein ständiges Reagieren. Und nur wenn man das sieht, und wenn man sieht, dass man Politik prinzipiell beeinflusst oder die Gesellschaft beeinflussen kann, dann kann man da auch aktiv agieren. Dann kann man sich auch überlegen, welche Projekte, welchen Einfluss haben werden und was man aus denen macht und wohin man damit sich selbst eigentlich stellt. Das ist wie, wenn man sagt, ja wir sind die Nerd, wir sind da draußen, schaut nicht auf uns, weil wir haben da unseren Hackerspace und da treffen wir uns und da treffen wir die Leute, die gleichgesinnt sind. Ja, das ist relativ passiv, da wird sich nichts ändern. Da kann man in einer kleinen Traumwelt, halt in seinem kleinen Space leben, da kann man auch zu Hause leben, das ist egal. Anders ist das, wenn man sich Sachen anschaut und eben was weiß ich, ein Gerät reverse-ingeniert und dann drauf kommt, das kann man verbessern und so ist es besser für zum Beispiel diesen lokalen gesellschaftlichen Rahmen.
Ja, und ich meine Social Engineering, um ein bisschen weitergetragen, kann natürlich auch ein, kann auch die Gesellschaft sozusagen Ort und Ziel und Aufgabe des Hackens sein. Ich meine, man kann ja eigentlich mit so viel klugen Leuten auch Modelle erarbeiten und im Prinzip ist ja auch ein Hackerspace selber ein solches Modell, ein Modell wie man zusammenarbeiten kann, wie man auf gleicher Augenhöhe Wissen vermitteln kann und wo alle was davon haben. Das ist ja ein Modell für die Gesellschaft, das ist sicherlich nicht das Modell, das alle Antworten liefert.
Aber das geht so. Man kann die Gesellschaft an sich ja im Großen ja nicht von heute auf morgen verändern. Es geht darum, sich Freiräume zu erkämpfen und diese Freiräume bis zu einem gewissen Grad zu nutzen.
Ja, aber es geht nicht darum, sie zu halten. Das ist etwas, was das TempLab, glaube ich, sehr auszeichnet, weil sie sich bewusst haben, dass sie temporär dort sind. Sie haben zwar alle erzeugt, aber die haben unglaublich viel Hardware dort. Aber sie könnten jeden Moment rausgeschmissen werden, dann müssen sie umziehen.
Sie sind insofern ein Hype-Squad.
Sie sind in einem aufgelassenen Bahnhofgelände mit einer Menge Künstlergruppen und so. Da sind ein paar Ateliers drin. Aber der Punkt ist, die überlegen sich nicht, was machen wir jetzt genau aus dieser Situation, dass wir die ganze Zeit rausgeschmissen werden könnten. Die überlegen sich, was haben wir generell für Ziele? Und wenn wir rausgeschmissen werden, dann machen wir die immer noch. Also es geht nicht darum, die Situation zu halten. Unser Hackerspace ist ein 200 Quadratmeter großer Raum. Wir haben so viele Mitglieder, wir versuchen, ein bisschen mehr zu kriegen. Wenn wir zu viele haben, dann holen wir uns einen größeren. Sondern die Frage ist, wie relativieren sich diese Ziele? Und ist irgendwann einmal der Hackerspace nicht mehr das drinnen, das kleine Eingekapselte, sondern wie geht das nach außen? Und wie adaptiere ich den Rest meiner Welt, den Rest meines Lebens zu dem, was ich gerne mache?
Wir sollten nicht vergessen, dass wenn der Hackerspace weg ist, einen Space irgendwo zu bekommen, das ist nicht das Problem. Das Wichtige, das war...
Wir haben gesehen, dass es ein generelles Problem war.
Man sollte sich dann schon noch ein bisschen von dieser... Also das Space ist wichtig, aber das Space ist noch das, was am einfachsten irgendwie zu bekommen ist, was relativ schwer wieder herstellbar ist, sind zerstörte, nicht funktionierte soziale Systeme. Soziale Gefüge. Wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann kann man 400 Quadratmeter Space haben und das ist einfach scheiße.
Aber die Frage ist einfach nur, wo ist das Ziel? Und wie definiere ich das Ziel? Und welchen Zusammenhalt hat das mit dem Rest der Außenwelt? Also das ist nicht einfach eine kleine Traumwelt, die halt jeder so ein Mal in der Woche, dreimal in der Woche, meinetwegen siebenmal in der Woche besucht. Und dann geht er raus und dann ist wieder alles beim Alten. Und so ändert sich nichts. Das ist circa wie das, was für ein Beispiel von einem Club war das vorher? So ein Freizeitclub, da kann ich auch hingehen, da werde ich die Welt nicht verändern. Man sollte sich einfach nur im Klaren darüber sein, dass dadurch, dass man Wissen verbreitet, dass das das Gesamt, die Konzeption von gesellschaftlichen Systemen verändern kann.
Ja, super Abschluss würde ich sagen, oder? Ja, ich denke, wir haben jetzt hier…
Du verlinkstest dir da eh alles auf der Seite, den Text und so.
Ich kann mir auf jeden Fall nichts mehr hinzufügen. Schöne Schlusswort. Ja, gut, vielleicht noch kurz hinterher. Ich denke, wer sich das bis hierhin durchgehört hat und jetzt auch zu diesen Leuten gehört, die sich kurz nach dem Vortrag eigentlich gerne melden möchten und fragen möchten, wer ist denn noch hier aus meiner Gegend dabei? Jetzt möchte ich auch in Hackerspace starten. Da gibt es Ressourcen bei hackerspaces.org. Das heißt, es gibt da auch so Gesuche. Also ich meine, fungiert das Wiki auch als Kontaktbörse?
Es ist so, wenn man ein wenig, wenn man schon festgestellt hat, man möchte ein Space irgendwo gründen, vielleicht hat man schon wen anders gefunden. Das ist immer sehr von Vorteil. Dann kann man sich auf die Liste eintragen mit einem temporären Namen als Planned. Also nicht als aktiver Hackerspace, nicht als einer, der gerade im Aufbau befindlich ist, sondern als, genau, weil dann, wenn jemand nach einem Space sucht, in seiner Gegend, sieht er, da ist einer geplant, dann sollte ich vielleicht mit ihm mal in Verbindung treten. Ganz wichtig, man sollte seine E-Mail-Adresse dort lassen. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele E-Mails ich in der Woche kriege, somit, diese IP-Adresse könnte der User-Name sein, nicht sicher. Hast du von dem mal die Kontaktdaten?
Also man muss hier nicht ins Wiki eintragen, aber vielleicht soll ich dort einen Benutzer-Account machen, sodass einem über das Wiki nachts geschickt werden kann.
Und was natürlich sinnvoll ist, mittlerweile gab es auch lange keinen großen Flame-War auf der Mailing-Liste. Schade eigentlich. Ganz klar, verpasst letztens. Ich kann gerne wieder mal ein Panflet schreiben, kein Problem.
Einfach mal wieder streitbar einmischen.
Einfach wieder streitbar einmischen. Nein, einfach auf die Mailing-Liste draufsetzen, weil es bisher immer relativ gut funktioniert hat, dass Leute, die sich auf der Mailing-Liste von hackerspaces.org quasi subscribiert haben und reingeschrieben haben, ich bin dort und dort, ich bin interessiert, ich würde gern was machen. Also, ich habe einen guten Freund in Orlando zum Beispiel. Und Orlando ist jetzt nicht das große Zentrum, ja in Florida genauer. Da gibt es halt nur Plastikmäuse und Orangen. Und das war es im Wesentlichen. Aber meine Eltern haben dort so eine Ferienwohnung und da fahre ich ab und zu mal hin und habe da auch Leute kennengelernt. Und irgendjemand hat dann auf die Mailing-Liste draufgeschrieben, hey, ich bin in Orlando, ich kenne da niemanden, ich würde da eigentlich gern was machen. Und da war ich zufällig auf der Liste drauf und habe gesagt, hey, da gibt es doch den und den Typen und der macht dieses Florida Creatives Ding, trifft euch doch mal mit dem. Und insofern ist so etwas, da ist glaube ich auch die Hackerspaces-Mailing-Liste total stark.
Ich glaube halt, dass es...
Es sind genug Leute oben, es ist so ein Initialmoment an genug Leuten, die genug Leute kennen, dass man weiterhelfen kann.
Ich glaube halt, dass man sowas distribuieren sollte. Auf einer Seite das Wiki, so für die Nachwelt, für irgendwen, der mal in drei Monaten vorbeischaut und was sucht in der Stadt. Als auch auf der Mailing-Liste, damit man eben in Kontakt treten kann mit bestimmten Leuten, die das nachträglich, so eine Woche nachher vielleicht, je nachdem, wie lange ihre E-Mail im Box so ist, nachlesen können. Als auch auf dem IRC-Channel, wo halt jemand direkt antworten kann. Und die Gespräche, die dort entstehen, sind wirklich, wirklich interessant. Wo Leute tatsächlich eine ganz, ganz praktische Frage stellen. Und dann kommen gleich einmal 10, 20 Reaktionen, weil circa 60 Leute zuständig kommen lassen, die gerne, gerne helfen bei Problemen, die einfach jeder dritte Hacker-Space mindestens schon mal gelöst hat. Es muss nicht jeder mit seiner neuen Problemlösungsstrategie aufkommen. Wir haben ja diese Versuche schon.
Anfall mich interessieren quasi, sagen, ex-refundable Blablablas für den US-amerikanischen Hackerspace ist eigentlich total Nüsse. Aber es ist scheinbar ein total großes Ding für die, quasi so ein Tax-Status und so ein Steuerrechts-Status zu kriegen und Blablabla. Und da gibt es ja genug Leute, die sich mit dem auseinandersetzen, Nick Farr und wer auch immer. Und für sowas funktioniert es ja sehr gut.
Pumping Station One hat ja ihre eigene Anwältin, die einfach so nebenbei... Ganz, ganz frisch. Die haben eben zum Beispiel eine Mitglieds-Anwältin, die hat auf der DevCon einen Talk gehalten über rechtliche Grundlagen für Hackerspaces. Also da gibt es mittlerweile echt vieles.
Eine Menge Ressourcen.
Na sicher. Und du wirst sie alle verlinken, hoffe ich.
Natürlich, natürlich. Deswegen kommt dieser Podcast auch so spät raus.
So, jetzt muss ich aber... Darf ich für den Jolic noch, für den Jens Olig noch was sagen? Ja, ich hab's hier mir extra aufgeschlagen. Der Marxscher Imperativ. Man darf ihn nicht vergessen. Man muss ihn immer wieder wiederholen. Es gilt, alle Verhältnisse umzuwerfen, in denen der Mensch ein erniedrigtes, ein geknechtetes, ein verlassenes und ein feuchtliches Wesen ist.
Okay, dann haben wir jetzt genug Schlussworte abgeliefert. Vielen Dank, Astera. Vielen Dank, Johannes.
Aber gerne.
Das war's, Chaosradio Express. Ausgabe Nummer 134. Und die letzte aus dem schönen Wien. Ich muss hier leider vorzeitig meine Zelte abbrechen und mich anderen wichtigen Dingen zuwenden. Das werde ich jetzt auch tun. Viel Glück mit der PlambaCon. Und auch viel Glück weiterhin mit dem Hackerspaces-Projekt. Ich hoffe, ihr seid jetzt alle motiviert. Wenn ihr bisher gezögert habt, dann auch mal euren eigenen Ort zu gründen in der einen oder anderen Form. Und dann tragt ihr euch auch gleich ganz fleißig in der tollen Karte ein, die vor roten Google-Barken nur so überquillt schon. Aber da ist auf jeden Fall noch Platz, wenn man genug weit reinzoomt. Ja, und das war's.